So Leute, da sind wir wieder und wie man sieht, ist meine Demo ausgelaufen.
Ne, nicht wirklich nice, aber das sackt.
Demo-Versionen, die auslaufen, sacken richtig.
So, ich muss jetzt erstmal warten, bis Twitch kapiert hat, dass der Stream online ist.
Das dauert ja immer so 5 Minuten oder so.
Selbst mein Browser kann sich nicht entscheiden, ob der Stream jetzt online ist oder nicht.
Ist auch geil, omegalull.
Mein Browser switcht die ganze Zeit bei dem Stream zwischen es ist online und es ist nicht
online.
Ich habe auch keine Zuschaueranzeige oder irgendwas, aber ich sehe die Vorschau.
Twitch hat sich noch nicht überlegt, ob der Stream jetzt online oder offline ist.
Oh, der Mr.
Army ist am Start.
Hast du Twitch-Benachrichtigung gekriegt oder hast du es einfach so gesehen, dass der Stream
online ist?
Twitch hat auch keine.
Wenn Twitch Benachrichtigungen verschickt hätte, dann wäre es nicht nur ein Zuschauer.
Bisschen laut, ne?
Wupp, wupp, wupp.
Besser.
Ganz so laut.
So, ich hoffe, dass Twitch...
This Ad supports Wupplots, kein Adblock in 2k19.
Ah, jetzt ist der Stream online.
Jetzt hat es Twitch gecheckt.
Nice.
Moin.
Jetzt sind die Leute am Start, ja.
Ich sehe das nämlich immer, wenn man...
Das ist ganz merkwürdig auf Twitch, wenn man den Stream anmacht, dann dauert es so
fünf Minuten oder so, bis Twitch die Nachrichten rausschickt, glaube ich, weil ich sitze meistens
die ersten fünf Minuten immer mit einem Zuschauer da und ein Zuschauer ist halt mein Vorschau,
mein Vorschaubild.
Und auf einen Schlag kommen dann immer irgendwie so ungefähr nach fünf Minuten, kommen dann
auf einen Schlag immer irgendwie zwanzig Leute und dann geht es halt raus.
Das ist halt so.
Schauen wir mal genauer.
Die machen es dann mal raus, die machen es dann mal raus.
Dann ist es ein Spiel, die zu kühlen und dafür...
First World Problems, ich weiß, Leute.
So, kann man das jetzt starten und...
Disable, disable, alles, alles, disablen.
Machen wir alles nicht.
Wow!
Munker Java!
Java-S.
Ist das jetzt...
Startet das jetzt, oder startet das jetzt nicht?
Ah, weiß es nicht.
Ah, ja, ok!
Jetzt geht's, ja.
Okay, was soll das?
Was soll das jetzt?
Ja, oh, okay.
auch immer java logik perfekt ich brauchte es ja eh nur um das programm zu starten dass ich
meinen chat mit mein chat log hab 98 prozent cpu als geht komm on bra ich glaube jetzt hat er es
geschafft man sieht hier wie das alles rein leckt aufschauen jetzt darf ich jetzt ich glaube jetzt
darf ich starte okay sehr schön ja leute also weiß nicht ob ich gesehen habt falls nicht das
jetzt noch mal zwar es gibt jetzt morgen gesehen für die switch gibt es den android seit gestern
offiziell also offiziell offiziell solchen leider nicht offiziell also nicht von nintendo oder so
aber es gibt jetzt den release
von den von den dudes als erstes offizielles release von den nicht von nintendo von nintendo
es klappt sie ja im leben durch frage kennst du welche router die waren bonding können das
kommt ein bisschen drauf an in welchem umfeld weil also willst du einfach nur interfaces bonden das
kann jeder bisschen bessere router oder jeder bisschen besseres mit
oder willst du wirklich zwei verschiedene nennen wir es mal ab links zu unterschiedlichen
providern bonden das könnte ja dann auch sein dass quasi bevor dem einen kabel modem ist und
vor dem anderen ein dsl modem oder dazwischen wenn du sowas willst dann brauchst du also entweder
laut balance du das das ist dann je nach
anwendung bringt das was oder bringt nix also das kannst du ohne gegenstellung machen du kannst
also das kannst du das laut balance das dürfte wahrscheinlich immer wieder einjeniger mit 200
ort gehörten keine fritzbox ist kann seine mikro tic tic nehmen oder sowas da kannst du einfach quasi
versuchen zu laut balance zwischen den anschlüssen du kannst wahrscheinlich sogar einstellen wenn
der eine schneller ist als der andere 80 prozent darüber 20 prozent darüber aber das sorgt für
Nicht dafür, dass du jetzt bei einem einzelnen Download, es sei denn du machst mehrere Sessions, aber so pauschal erstmal nicht, dass du bei einem Download jetzt anstatt, keine Ahnung, 100 Mbit, 200 Mbit hast.
Das ist gut dafür, wenn du mehrere Benutzer dahinter hast mit unterschiedlichen Verbindungen.
Dann funktioniert eigentlich Loadbalancen über zwei Internetleitungen ganz gut.
Für einen einzelnen Download eher nicht so und also für einen einzelnen User eher nicht so gut.
Und wenn du wirklich das, sagen wir mal so, bonden willst, dass das eine einzelne Verbindung benutzen kann, dann brauchst du auf der Gegenseite irgendeinen Tunnel-Endpunkt oder irgendeinen Endpunkt, der das auch kann.
Also dann nimmst du entweder einen, oh wie heißt das, wie heißt der Kram?
Ich muss mir mal Gedanken zu machen, wie der Kram hieß.
Das macht man so selten.
Oder zumindest so selten, wenn man nicht irgendwie meine...
Dann brauchst du so einen Multi-Point-Dings-Endpunkt und das kann beispielsweise ein selbst gemieteter Linux-Server sein, bei Hetzner oder irgendwo anders oder irgendeine selbst gemietete VM, die die entsprechende Bandbreite hat.
Und dann musst du von einem Router zu deiner Kiste im Internet, baust du dann quasi einen, baust du mehr oder weniger so einen Layer-2-Bonding drüber von einem Router.
Über die Internetanschlüsse zu deinem Server.
Das heißt, dein Ausgang ist auch der Server, den du gemietet hast.
Das ist aber relativ kompliziert.
Also, so einfach, ich habe zwei Internetanschlüsse und möchte die bonden, geht gar nicht.
Also entweder brauchst du eine Gegenstelle, die das kann, musst du halt selbst installieren oder irgendwas Fertiges holen.
Oder aber, du loadbalancest einfach zwischen den beiden Internetanschlüssen.
Das bringt dir dann aber für eine einzelne Verbindung nichts.
Das ist halt wiederum relativ einfach.
Wenn du jetzt, sagen wir mal, wenn du jetzt irgendwie eine, keine Ahnung, 2, 3, 4, 5-köpfige Familie seid, dann ist das Loadbalancen zwischen Internetanschlüssen gar nicht verkehrt.
Weil dann kannst, dann kannst, was weiß ich, da können die Kinder aus Netflix streamen über Telekom-Anschluss und du kannst irgendwie Steam downloaden über Unity Media.
Also das funktioniert.
Dafür ist ein Loadbalancen zwischen zwei Internetanschlüssen okay, aber halt nicht für eine einzelne Verbindung.
Hat man das verstanden?
Ansonsten wird es echt komplizierter.
Wenn du die wirklich zusammen für eine Verbindung verwenden willst.
Das ist nicht so, das ist nicht so einfach.
Also das ist nicht so einfach gemacht, wenn man macht ein Häkchen rein.
Da brauchst du auf jeden Fall eine Gegenstelle, die das auch kann.
Ich hab, ich hab vergessen, wie das heißt.
Multi, Multipoint.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Müsste ich, müsste ich genauer nachgucken, wie der ganze Kampel heißt.
Ja, moin Leute.
Also für alle, die jetzt gerade eingeschaltet haben.
Ich hab heute Morgen gesehen, es gibt.
Es gibt jetzt für die Switch, muss ich auf meinem Browser mal überlegen, wie das aussehen soll.
Sollte, sollte das nicht vielleicht so ein bisschen verlieren oder so?
Naja, egal.
Ich hab heute Morgen gesehen, es gibt jetzt für die Switch, gibt's, gibt's im Android halt natürlich kein offizielles von Nintendo.
Allerdings haben die jetzt wohl eins, die Typen, die da dran arbeiten, jetzt wohl eins released.
Das Ganze basiert offline.
So, es ist 15.1, wo anscheinend Oreo drunter ist.
Und es ist relativ naheliegend, dass es das ist, weil in der Switch ist ja mehr oder weniger das, was in den Nvidia Shield-Dingern drin ist.
Das heißt, es sollte von der Architektur her relativ einfach sein, rein zum Laufen zu bringen, ja.
Das, das Shield-Android.
Das Problem ist bloß.
Das halt.
Das ist halt die, äh, Switch im Endeffekt nichts davon hat, was ein Tablet hat, ja.
Also du hast keine Kameras, wobei ich weiß gar nicht, hat die Switch eine Kamera?
Eine steht im Wohnzimmer, ich kann nicht gucken.
Hat die Switch eigentlich eine Kamera?
Ähm, zumindest hat die Switch definitiv kein Mikrofon und sowas.
Es sei denn, wenn man irgendwie diese komische, komische App verwendet.
So, wir gucken uns das mal an.
Wir gucken uns mal an, was man so machen kann mit dem Android für die Switch.
signed out
ère
How's it going?
It's awesome.
Like.
Oh yeah.
Yeah!
That's great.
Ah, wow.
Is is all but okay. We're really glad you did that!
If you've kept up with the Nintendo Switches development scene as of late, you'll have noticed that there's a lot of cool things happening right now. Between the launch of Linux for Tegra, Ubuntu...
...bylaws, and the release of EmuMMC for the Switch, there's never been a better time to own a hackable Nintendo Switch.
Hast du beruflich eigentlich auch mit externen Personen zu tun, oder nur mit internen? Bist du mal einem Zuschauer...
...auch ja, Zuschauern bin ich begegnet, und auf der Arbeit sind 95% interne Leute.
Aber ich bin auch niemand, der sich dafür eignet, großartig mit Außendienst oder irgendwelchen anderen Leuten Kontakt zu haben.
Die gehen ja prinzipiell eh alle Leute auf den Sack, und wenn man im Außendienst ist,
beziehungsweise mit Leuten zu tun hat,
dann muss man da halt auch ein bisschen schleimen
und das kriege ich nicht hin.
Oder wenigstens ein bisschen nett sein,
wenn man merkt, die Leute sind nervig.
Ja, also da bin ich auch der Falsche für.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Am besten war mal,
wo ich wieder gesehen habe,
dass ich niemals Hotline oder so ein Blödsinn machen will,
ist,
es hat mal irgendeine,
von einem anderen Standort
hat man eine Mail geschrieben an unser Postfach
und die, oh fuck,
ich habe fast wieder meinen Tee verschüttet,
und die wollte offensichtlich nicht zu uns.
Die hat irgendwas gefragt,
so nach dem Motto, warum geht,
warum geht das System nicht?
Also so die übliche Frage, die man an der Hotline immer kriegt.
Also warum geht das System nicht?
Da habe ich mir gedacht,
okay, die ist jetzt zwar bei uns rausgekommen,
aber ich weiß, dass die definitiv nicht zu uns will.
Also,
ähm, habe ich mir gedacht, ey komm, bist du mal nett?
Das war schon der erste Fehler.
Ähm,
und habe mir zurückgeschrieben, äh,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr, um welches System es geht,
und ich, ähm,
denke, sie ist bei uns falsch,
sie soll bei der Hotline anrufen.
Aber anstatt, dass sie bei der Hotline angerufen hätte,
hat sie mir zurückgeschrieben,
von welchem System sie spricht.
Und zwar hat sie geschrieben,
es geht um das System, mit dem wir täglich arbeiten.
Bitte schnellstens Fehler beheben.
So, und dann habe ich mir nur das hier gedacht, ja.
Worum alles in der Welt ist, soll ich wissen?
Mit welchem System sie täglich arbeitet?
Ich weiß nur,
dass wir garantiert nicht für dieses System da sind.
Das ist so, das ist, ich, deswegen,
ich will definitiv nicht bei der Hotline,
nie, nie will ich bei der Hotline arbeiten, ne.
Ich meine, auf die Frage hin, welches System,
zu antworten, das System, mit dem wir täglich arbeiten,
das ist echt schon ziemlich bescheuert.
Ich meine, die weiß, die wusste das nicht besser, ja.
Aber es ist trotzdem irgendwie beknackt.
Naja, und übrigens, letztens habe ich auch wieder,
äh, die,
die volle,
hab ich mal gucken, hab ich auf Twitter gepostet,
die volle BWL-Logik mitbekommen.
Achso, übrigens, meine China-USB-Kabel sind da.
Wer es nicht auf Twitter gesehen hat.
Ähm, das sind 50 USB-Kabel,
Micro-USB auf USB-C,
also normal auf Micro-USB,
und da ist ein Stecker dabei mit USB-C.
Das heißt, man hat alles abgefackelt, was man so braucht.
Warum so viele?
Weil die bei Aliexpress nur 46 Euro gekostet haben,
inklusive BWL-Logik.
Inklusive Versand.
Also das heißt, wir haben 50,
äh,
also für 92 Cent,
für 92 Cent
pro, äh, pro USB.
Bitte um Link, äh, ich hab's versucht
auf Twitter zu posten, hat nämlich schon jemand
gefragt, allerdings gibt's das Angebot nicht mehr.
Du musst mal bei Aliexpress suchen.
Such einfach bei Aliexpress, äh,
2 in 1, in einem, in einem
Wort geschrieben,
2 in 1 USB,
und da musst du dich mal ein bisschen durchscrollen,
kannst irgendwie noch so viel dabei
eingeben, oder 50,
oder irgendwas, und dann
irgendwann, wenn du dich hier mal durchscrollst,
wirst du so diese 50er, 100er, teilweise
sogar 250er Bundles finden.
Ah, hier geht's schon in die richtige
Richtung. Und dann musst du dir einfach
noch ein günstiges raussuchen.
Das sind, das sind
bestimmt auch ein paar. Das sind 500 Stück,
guck mal. Also,
das ist wirklich bei Aliexpress echt
günstig.
Aber 92 Cent pro USB-Kabel
ist sehr nice. Wenn man sich überlegt,
da ist ja Versand schon dabei gewesen. DHL-
Versand, wohlgemerkt. Ich kann nicht verstehen, ob
die überhaupt an dem USB-Kabel was verdient haben.
Ähm,
ich verk...
Also, ich hab, ich hab mal ein paar Kabels ausprobiert,
die funktionieren eigentlich ganz gut. Und
es stimmt ja gar nicht, dass China nur Schrott verkauft.
Du hast die Chance, wenn du halt
billig kramst bei Aliexpress kaufst, dass das Schrott
ist, ist halt relativ hoch.
Ähm, aber wenn...
Es gibt auch mittlerweile gute China-Sachen. Beispielsweise
einen Staubsauger-Roboter, den ich hab. Das ist echt gut,
das Teil. Verkaufst du die? Nein.
Ich behalte die.
Weil, ich hab mir die ja bestellt.
Ähm,
dass ich quasi für die nächsten Jahre
genug USB-Kabel hab. Deswegen hab ich auch
explizit welche gesucht, die
USB auf Micro-USB
sind und USB-C. Weil,
das ist das, was du für die nächsten Jahre brauchst.
Aktuell hast du zum größten Teil
noch Micro-USB.
Und, ähm,
in Zukunft hast du immer mehr USB-C.
So, und das hast du jetzt in Kombination. Jetzt
hast du USB auf Micro-USB oder alternativ
auf USB-C. Also besser, besser
kann's eigentlich gar nicht funktionieren.
Die Musik bisschen laut. Ah ja, weil ich zu laut gemacht hab.
Ja.
Genau, ähm, wollte ich euch
aber jetzt eigentlich gar nicht zeigen. Zumindest die Kabel sind da.
Ich wurde nichts gar maßt. Die sind angekommen.
Die funktionieren. Und ich finde, es sieht auf
einem Haufen viel mehr aus, als ich gedacht hab.
Ähm, so. Und...
Letztens hab ich wieder die...
Hier, das da. So geil. Hab ich
eine Aussage auf der Arbeit, ne? Ist auch geil.
Hat irgendjemand erzählt,
hat irgendjemand erzählt, ich glaub, das war aus dem
Datenbankumfeld, hat jemand erzählt,
also, unsere SLA's
sagen maximal 30 Minuten Datenverlust.
Und da hab ich gesagt, ja, okay, und was,
was machen wir, wenn's länger dauert?
Und da kam der absolut big,
die big brain Aussage schlechthin,
wir schalten einfach das System ab, damit
wir keine Daten mehr bekommen.
Das ist, das ist
massive brain, ey.
Man hat quasi zugesagt,
man hat maximal 30 Minuten Datenverlust,
und wenn's länger dauert, nimmt man
einfach keine neuen Daten mehr an, dass man
nicht mehr als 30 Minuten Datenverlust hat.
Das ist, das ist huge. Das ist wirklich
ganz, ganz groß.
Big brain, ey.
Das ist wieder so die typische, typische BWL-Logik, ey.
Was sind SLA's? Das sind,
das ist quasi ein Vertrag, den du hast
mit irgendjemand, wo drinsteht, wie
verfügbar was ist.
Service Level Agreement heißt das.
Wobei ich mir bei euch immer nicht
sicher bin, bei meinem Chat, weil ich weiß ja, dass ich,
dass ich big brain Chat hab,
ob die Leute das wirklich fragen, oder ob die das fragen
so nach dem Motto, who cares, SLA's.
Okay.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal an, also Android, Android
auf der Switch.
Ubuntu.
Moment, Moment, erstmal
Sound aus.
Okay.
EMU MMC ist doch echt, das ist doch der
Switch-Emulator, oder?
Ich find das so geil, dass man dann auf der Switch
die Switch emulieren kann.
Never been a better time to own a
hackable Nintendo Switch.
Now, bylaws has one-upped themselves, as you
can soon turn your Nintendo Switch into a full-fledged
Android-Tablet, complete with Dock
and Joy-Con support.
Before the public release, we had the opportunity to test
Android on the Nintendo Switch to see what it can do.
Spoiler alert, there's a lot.
I'm Adam Conway with XGA TV,
and this is Lineage OS running on
the Nintendo Switch.
For better or for worse, the Nintendo Switch
was never meant to be more than a simplistic
gaming device, suffering from even the
lack of a native web browser.
Ich hab einen Fleck auf dem Bildschirm sehe ich gerade, wenn der Hintergrund so weiß ist.
Seht ihr den auch?
Das hat
mal Dings hier, hat mal Bibis
Beauty Palace auf Twitter gepostet.
So nach dem Motto, oh mein Gott,
ich hab einen Bildschirmfehler,
und hab einen Screenshot von gemacht.
Das war auch Massive
Brain, ja. Wobei ich mir
bei der gar nicht so sicher bin, ob die blöd ist, in der
Richtung, oder ob das einfach
der übelste Debate ist, dass die Leute
reacten auf Twitter.
Da hab ich ja drauf gewartet,
Linux zu starten auf der
Switch, damit ich dann Minecraft
auf der Switch, also dass
ich dann unter Linux Minecraft
auf der Switch spielen kann. Gibt's
Minecraft nicht eh schon für die Switch mittlerweile?
Also fast alles alte
für die Switch.
Es gibt sogar Doom für die Switch.
Ich hab am Morgen
auch in den News gelesen, dass
es gibt jetzt Doom 1, 2, 3
für die Switch.
Allerdings hat sich Bethesda
gedacht, wir können da ja kein 30 Jahre
altes Game auf der Switch ohne
DRM releasen.
Und ähm
jetzt haben sie in
Doom 1 hat Bethesda DRM eingebaut
für die Switch. Da können wir
uns auch gleich noch ein Video zu angucken.
Das stimmt.
Ich bin geneigt dazu, das mal mit
meiner Switch auszuprobieren,
weil ich verwende meine Switch eh so gut
wie nicht. Und ich hab
eine Release Switch.
Die ist mit Sicherheit alt genug,
dass das funktioniert.
... Release.
There is also going to be a
pre-packaged version of TWRP,
which you can then use to flash a
Google Apps ZIP package and optionally
an your Nintendo Switch.
... release.
There is also going to be a pre-packaged version of TWRP,
which you can then use to flash a Google Apps ZIP package and optionally
an Nvidia Apps Package as well.
Mruch of this Port was made possible by the fact
that the Android based Nvidia Shield runs on the exact same
Chipset as the Nintendo Switch, the Tegra X1.
Oh God.
But technicalities aside. what can you do that you couldn't before?
For starters, the Joycons work natively and support
pretty much anything that already supported a
controller. That means, you can
Also I can install Linux on Shutles on my Switch,
then I can play Portal 2 on LINUX.
At the moment, there is already a port
Es gibt keinen Emulator für den Nintendo Switch, der DS-Games auf voller Geschwindigkeit funktionieren kann, obwohl es bei Android Emulatoren gibt, die, wie Drastic, schon seit Jahren funktionieren können.
Ich habe Pokémon Platinum auf voller Geschwindigkeit auf meinem Switch gespielt ohne irgendwelche Probleme.
Der Tegra X1 ist nicht der stärkste Chipset, aber es wird viel von dem funktionieren, was du drauf hast.
Für das, wenn man sich überlegt, wie alt diese Tegra-Plattform ist, ist das ziemlich schnell.
Die Tegra X1 ist auch eine Mediakonsumption-Büste.
Mit ihrer Dockingstation und 1080p-Video-Output ist sie ein Gerät, das perfekt zu den Likes von Netflix passt.
Wenn du dich auf deinem TV-Show oder Film anschauen möchtest, drückst du es einfach in die Dockingstation und weitergibst, wenn es keine Interruptionen gibt.
Auf Android ist das gleiche seamless Dockingsystem hier und es gibt auch Unterstützung für Netflix, obwohl du die APK von irgendwo in der Google Play Store installieren musst.
Weil es kein Widevine DRM für HD gibt, kannst du nur auf Netflix und bis zu 560p sehen.
Ja, okay.
Das ist gut.
Das kann ich verstehen, ne?
Du darfst ja Netflix in eurer Auflösung nur gucken, wenn du HDCP und sowas kannst.
Also wenn dein HDMI-HDCP und dein Fernseh-HDCP und alles HDCP kann zwischendurch.
Das Touch auf der Switch sagt übelst.
Wozu?
Das Beste daran dürfte sein, dass man endlich einen ordentlichen Browser auf der Switch hat.
Dafür lohnt sich das.
Weil Nintendo hat es ja immer noch nicht geschafft.
Oder?
Ich habe schon ewig, ewig die Switch nicht mehr angehabt.
Letztes Mal, wo ich News geguckt habe, gab es immer noch keinen Browser.
... advanced Codecs like LDAC or APTX, which leaves you with good old A2DP, so expect a lot of latency and high power consumption.
Not every application supports the Joy-Cons yet either.
Dolphin Emulator did not like the analog sticks and Steam Link doesn't either.
When Steam Link does work, you'll be able to stream all of your favorite games from your PC to your Switch and play anywhere in your home.
Which is pretty neat, to say the least.
Das ist nice, ja.
Kannst du Steam Play machen vom PC aus.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Wobei, dazu brauchst du nicht unbedingt eine Switch, ne?
Weil das Coole an der Switch ist, dass da ein Controller mit dabei ist.
Still, it's a first release and a very good one at that.
If you enjoyed this video, be sure to give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the channel.
Ich würde das sogar mal ausprobieren hier.
Ich würde das sogar eigentlich mal on-Stream ausprobieren.
Die Sache ist die, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob man sowas on-Stream ausprobieren darf.
Weil, ne, mon gratos.
Make sure to check out the Nintendo Switch XDA forums in the description.
And let us know in the comments what you think.
Ich hätte schon Bedenken, das Forum hier überhaupt aufzumachen on-Stream.
Ja, das stimmt, mon gratos, das mache ich nicht.
Genau, wir gucken jetzt nochmal das Video.
Doom DRM Switch, das ist richtig.
Das ist massiv hängen geblieben.
Das ist massiv hängen geblieben, ja.
Ja.
Das ist richtig, richtig bescheuert.
Muss man sich jetzt mal überlegen, ja.
Das habe ich mir heute Morgen schon zur Hälfte angeguckt.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
Das Doom Release auf der Switch.
Und das Xbox One X.
Das ist eine tolle Sache, die Bethesda gemacht hat,
die alten Porten der Doom-Spiele in einer offiziellen Qualität
in die moderne Konsole zu bringen.
Und sie sind auch sehr gut gekostet.
$4,99 für Doom 1 und Doom 2.
Und $9,99 für Doom 3.
Nun, auf dem Papier sollte das ein Must-Buy sein für die meisten Fans von Doom.
Aber wie wir sehen, sind die Dinge ein bisschen komplizierter als das.
Um mit QuakeCon 2019 zusammenzukommen, hat Bethesda gerade erklärt,
dass die ersten drei Doom-Spiele, die heute vorhanden sind...
Der muss mal gucken, dass sein Audio immer gleich laut ist.
... auf der Nintendo Switch und auch auf der Xbox One und PS4.
Aber wisst ihr was? Um diese Spiele zu spielen,
müsst ihr die Internetseite verbinden
und entweder loggen oder kreieren.
Das ist doch Fail.
Das ist ein Game aus einer Zeit,
da hatte noch nicht mal jemand einen Internetanschluss daheim.
Okay, ganz wenige, ganz wenige hatten einen, ja.
Ja.
Die haben wirklich ein Game genommen von...
Genau, 93, steht hier oben.
Und haben Online-Zwang eingebaut.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Das ist richtig Fail.
... ein neues Bethesda.net-Account.
Das ist richtig, Leute.
DRM auf einem 26-jährigen Spiel ist eine Realität,
dank Bethesda.
Nicht zu erwähnen, die fünf Seiten der Terms des Servers,
auf die ihr zu akzeptieren müsst,
bevor ihr das Spiel spielen könnt.
Das ist so Fail.
Und ich wünschte, ich könnte euch sagen, dass es dort endet.
Auf der anderen Seite,
hat Bethesda die Entscheidung genommen,
die Xbox Live Arcade Version von Doom zu entfernen,
die ihr auf Xbox 360 und Xbox One X
via Backward Compatibility spielen könnt.
Diese Version hat kein solches DRM in der Lage.
DRM oder Digital Rights Management
auf einem 26-jährigen Spiel ist einfach dumm.
Sprecher haben jedes Recht,
ihre IP und Assets von Piraten zu beschützen.
Aber ich muss euch sagen,
das ist nicht der richtige Ansatz.
Doom wurde zu fast jedem Gerät in Deutschland gefordert.
Es ist open source.
Und wenn ihr ein registriertes WAD-File habt,
dann, für alle Intentionen...
Ich meine, du kannst das Game auf einem Drucker spielen mittlerweile, ne?
Aber um es auf der Switch zu spielen,
brauchst du einen Bethesda-Online-Zwang-Account.
Ihr habt Doom.
Ich habe mehr Kopien des Spiels,
von denen ich mich überhaupt erinnern kann.
4,99 Dollar für eine Switch-Porte ist perfekt in Ordnung.
Aber eine Internet-Konnexion zu benötigen,
um eine Bethesda.net-Account
zur Kopie von Doom zu verlinken,
ist schuldig.
Doom läuft auf meinem Drucker.
Das ist jetzt kein Witz.
Doom läuft wirklich auf meinem Drucker.
Wad? Moment.
Die haben nicht das Original-Game genommen,
die haben Doom in Unity nachgebaut.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Habe ich das gerade richtig verstanden?
Use Unity instead of the original source code,
which means that the vanilla...
But why?
Das ist ja noch nicht mal Doom.
Das ist ja quasi dann ein offizieller Doom-Klon.
The 35 Hz Doom that you might be used to,
won't be found here.
Aside from the terrible DRM,
my biggest issue is that the music has been slowed down,
for no real apparent reason at all.
Here is what it should sound like.
And here is the Bethesda port.
Das hört sich nicht nur langsam an,
das hört sich...
Das hört sich übelst...
übelst plechern an, oder?
To illustrate further,
here is the first level of Doom 2.
Das hört sich übelst kaputt an.
Das hört sich alle als kack die Switch gleich ab.
Doom 3, on the other hand,
was ported by Panic Button,
known for the Wolfenstein and Doom 2016 ports
to the Nintendo Switch,
they are the masters of getting Doom games to run.
And Doom 3 is no exception.
It runs at a superb 1080p...
Haben die das auch in Unity nachgebaut?
Das stellt sich mir ein bisschen aufwendig vor.
...60 frames per second in dock mode
and 720p 60 frames in handheld mode.
It looks and plays great.
Das ist halt Doom 3.
So, why do I care so much about Bethesda?
Ich muss ja sagen, ich bin persönlich gar kein
großartiger Fan von Doom 3.
Ich fand so die ersten 1-2 Stunden
waren echt nice.
Ähm...
Aber es ist halt überall dunkel
und es ist überall...
hinter jeder Tür ist irgendwas
und das ist irgendwie...
Doom 3 ist nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Der Anfang hat übelst Bock gemacht
und Doom 3 ist sowieso...
die erste Hälfte ist nice
und danach ist irgendwie langweilig.
Also mir hat Doom 3 nicht sonderlich gut gefallen.
...Port of Doom.
Well, a few things to mention.
I've made ports of Doom on the original Xbox,
Sony PSP and Nintendo Switch.
So I think that...
Ich mein, Doom läuft...
Das läuft auf allem.
...have some say in this.
Thanks to the homebrew community,
and even Doom 64,
have been available on the Nintendo Switch
for over a year now,
in a free legal capacity,
with no DRM at all.
The way that it was intended.
I've even made a video about porting Doom
to the Nintendo Switch in 45 minutes
and how it can be achieved.
My video was also mentioned in Fabian Sanglard's book...
Kannst du nochmal den tanzenden Pipel sagen?
Kann ich machen, ja.
Aber das passt jetzt nicht so, weil das ist kein Sound.
...all about Doom.
I hate to say homebrew leads to piracy,
but the reality is homebrew is helping preserve
video games like Doom
long after Bethesda.net
has gone offline forever.
DRM has no place in a 26 year old...
Ich mein, das ist doch voll affig,
irgendwo.
Warum soll ich da...
Ey, Leute,
jetzt, die haben doch gesagt,
ähm, sie haben Sinunity nachgebaut.
Was meint ihr,
wie hoch die Chance ist,
nur, dass sie einfach DRM
einbauen können?
Weil ich glaube,
DRM in das Original Doom,
also den Original Source Code
von Doom zu nehmen und da irgendwie
DRM reinzustricken,
war wahrscheinlich komplizierter,
als Doom in Unity
nachzubauen und dann halt
nur noch 15 DRM von heute
zu nehmen.
Wie wahrscheinlich haltet ihr das,
dass die das nur in Unity nachgebaut haben,
um DRM einzubauen?
100%
Ich denke auch, ja,
es klingt irgendwie logisch.
Es klingt irgendwie logisch.
Ja, total überflüssig.
Ich denke auch, ja,
es klingt irgendwie logisch.
Der Witz daran ist auch,
ähm, wenn die sich jetzt denken,
ey, Leute, wir haben keinen Bock,
das Spiel weiter auf der Switch
irgendwie anzubieten,
da können sie einfach sagen, oh ja, eingestellt.
Es bedeutet ja auch,
es gibt mehr Angst und Frustration
von Kunden und ich habe bereits
auf Twitter Berichte gesehen,
dass Leute nicht auf den Login gehen können
oder Fehler beim Login,
Authentizierung, Teil der Verarbeitung,
was bedeutet, dass sie dieses Spiel
kaufen, das sie vielleicht nicht
spielen können.
Natürlich ist es ein einziger
DRM-Check, und wenn es fertig ist,
dann bist du gut zu gehen.
Ich verstehe diesen Aspekt des Spiels,
Ja, das sehe ich auch so.
Es ist, es ist fair.
Ich würde sagen, dass, du weißt, vergesst nicht, dieses Spiel zu kaufen.
Ich meine, der beste Weg, um Bethesda zu wissen, dass du nicht glücklich bist mit den DRM-Messungen, ist es, das Spiel nicht zu kaufen.
Ja, ist ja im Prinzip bei allen Games so, ne?
Also wenn einem Battlefield nicht gefällt, das Beste, was man machen kann, ist, kein Battlefield zu kaufen.
Und man hat das ja gesehen bei Battlefront, da ist die EA-Aktie erstmal von Allzeit hoch zu
runtergefallen.
Vor allem hat es dann Disney noch gesagt.
Nee, damit wollen wir nichts zu tun haben.
Was, der hat große Icons auf dem Desktop?
Echt?
Gut, der hat große Icons auf dem Desktop.
Was hat er denn auf dem Desktop?
Lass mal gucken.
Wir stalken jetzt mal, was er auf dem Desktop hat.
Discord, GitHub, Notepad++, WinRar, WinRar in 2019, Skype,
Corsair, Q, RGB-Beleuchtung, Chrome, irgendeine Karotte, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll, Speedfan, also Speedfan in 2019 ist das auch noch ein Ding, irgendein Bild, erkenne ich nicht, VLC, das ist irgendein Office-Ding, oder?
Das ist irgendein Office, das ist OBS, sieht OBS echt so aus?
Tatsächlich, das ist OBS.
Aber Speedfan sieht auch so aus.
Speedfan-Dogo sieht genauso aus.
Das hat mich jetzt verwirrt.
Ja, ihr habt recht, das ist OBS.
Audacity.
Steam, Portal, ist das Portal?
Was ist das?
Portal, nee, was ist denn das?
Das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Rest erkenne ich nicht.
Okay, genug Icons gestalkt.
Ach, Destiny, nicht Portal, Destiny war es.
Ja, jetzt bei der Gelegenheit, ich muss jetzt auch mal meine Desktop-Icons vergrößern.
Wie groß, ah, mehr größer geht nicht.
So ist gut, oder?
Würde ich sagen, von der Größe her.
Dann sieht man wenigstens alles.
Dann sieht man auch Max Revealed, ja.
So ist doch top.
Da erkennt man wenigstens, was am Desktop ist.
Leute, das laggt.
Das Vergrößern von Icons laggt unter Windows.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit denen los ist.
Wie?
Wie klein geht's maximal?
Aha.
Machen wir so.
Auch schön fett.
Was ist die beste WinRAR-Alternative?
7-zip ist das Beste, was man eigentlich verwenden kann.
7-zip kann alles.
Wisst wahrscheinlich so ein paar ganz exotische Extensions von irgendwelchen Packprogrammen oder so.
7-zip, beste.
Kost nichts, Open Source, gibt's für jedes Betriebssystem.
Wüsste gar nicht, warum ich was anderes verwenden sollte, außer...
...ausser 7-zip.
Ja, aber es ist richtig beknackt, DRM auf extra ein Spiel in Unity nachgebaut, nur, dass man DRM drauf einbauen kann.
Denn Google Home geht an, wenn ich was sag.
Ja, siehst du, das ist ein Grund, warum ich weder Alexa noch Google Assistant hier irgendwo stehen hab.
Ich sag jetzt nicht die Standardwörter dafür, sonst gehen bei euch wahrscheinlich Alexa und Google Assistant die ganze Zeit an.
Das wollte ich noch gucken.
Ich hab ja, ich mach mir ja mittlerweile für die Sonntagsmorgen-Streams immer eine Liste an Sachen, die ich gucken will.
Und schreib mir das in ein Textdokument, dass wir das dann theoretisch on-Stream gucken können.
Es gibt nämlich den neuen, hab ich gesehen, es gab vor elf Tagen oder so, oder wann, vor einem Monat, gab's den neuen Super Mario World Speedrun-Record.
Den wollte ich mir nochmal angucken.
Weil das ultra nice zu gucken ist.
Und wo ich mich immer frage, wie die Leute manche Sachen machen.
Ähm, hast du das neue Video von Elektro Boom gesehen?
Ne, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Was gibt's denn für ein neues Video?
EMP-Device.
Dann wird er sich wahrscheinlich wieder 20 mal selber schocken, hä?
Komm.
Ah, das guck ich mir nachher an.
Manchmal, manchmal weiß ich gar nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich mir manche Videos bookmarke, ne?
Ich hab mir hier so ein typisches 0815-Skamars-Video, also wo ich jetzt schon weiß, dass es Skamars ist, das Video, gebookmarkt.
Für später angucken.
Diese elf Tricks werden dein Leben unendlich besser machen.
Warum bookmarke ich mir sowas?
Wenn ich den Titel schon sehe, weiß ich, es ist Skamars.
Warum wollte ich mir das angucken?
Und wahrscheinlich sind wieder 50% der Tricks übelster Bullshit.
Ich mein...
Das gucken wir jetzt mal.
Wir gucken jetzt mal absichtlich Skamars-Video an.
Oh.
Da werden wir sehen, dass das totale Bullshit ist wahrscheinlich.
So, Bewertung ist schon mal...
Naja, geht so.
Oh, was ist das?
Waren wir jetzt im Schnellverfahren?
Also, ich mein, allein schon, allein schon der Titel, ne?
Diese elf Tricks werden dein Leben unendlich besser machen.
Oh Gott, das ist so grausam.
Okay, also, erster Trick ist, wie man schneller Fahrstuhl fährt.
Okay.
Springen.
Wir gucken das jetzt nicht.
Wir gucken uns das mal an.
Drücke gleichzeitig die Taste Tür und Schließung und die Nummer der Etage, die du willst.
Das funktioniert wahrscheinlich bloß bei den Fahrstuhlen, wo das in der Firmware so drin ist.
Oh.
Wechsel-Trick.
Man kann einen Kochlöffel auf den Topf legen, dass es nicht überläuft.
Oh nein, wer hätte das gedacht?
Das ist ja auch schon relativ alt.
Ähm...
Man kann Salat schälen.
Äh, ne, Salat kleinschneiden.
Man kann...
Was?
Ach so.
Okay, jetzt hat man so quasi diesen, diesen...
Wie heißt denn das da?
Diesen Wurzelansatz raus.
Aber man muss es trotzdem noch schneiden.
Man kann mit einem Deckel die Chili-Schote...
Okay.
Na gut, na gut, na gut.
Das ist, das ist bestimmt der alte, der alte Hemdenfall-Trick über Kreuz, hä?
Oder das, oder, oder, oder das Aufrollen.
Das Aufrollen.
Das, das Machen, das hab ich auch schon gesehen.
Ja, es ist das Aufrollen.
Easy.
Kennt man auch schon.
Okay.
Krasser Hack, jetzt wird das Handy zugeklebt.
The fuck?
Es ist blaues Licht.
Und was tut es?
Es leuchtet blau.
Ich stehe.
Es ist blaues Licht.
Das glaub ich nicht.
Wie hoch ist der UV-Anteil von so einer Handy-LED?
Das könnte ich mir höchstens vorstellen.
Ähm.
Wenn, also, dass das Licht blau ist, das verstehe ich.
Ja, ich meine, er hat blauen Edding davor geschmiert.
Und dass das jetzt so leuchtet, dürfte eher daran liegen,
dass das halt einfach Schaum ist, der weiß ist,
und der halt nun mal...
hervorsticht, wenn man ihn anleuchtet.
Ja, ja, Chat, ihr habt recht, sehe ich genauso.
Das ist übelst der Bullshit.
Skamaz, sag ich so, Skamaz-Video, ja.
Ja, was heißt Schaum?
Das ist sowas wie Schaum.
Sieht man doch, das sieht...
Das könnte, das könnte, das könnte, was könnte das sein?
Seife?
Seife oder Farbe?
Das könnten Farbkleckse sein, das könnte...
Irgendeiner, der seinen Rasierschaum da irgendwie dran gekleckst hat.
Irgend, irgendwas, was auf jeden Fall von...
sich aus schon recht hell aussieht, wenn du es anleuchtest.
Das ist auf jeden Fall Skamaz.
Es gibt das jetzt, wenn es fertig ist.
Oder einfach, genau, oder einfach mit der Taschenlampe daneben geleuchtet.
Hä?
Okay, wozu?
Wozu?
Okay, was auch immer.
So Hemdfalter sind echt nice, ich weiß nicht, ob man das braucht.
Ich meine, okay, wenn man es braucht, dann ist es...
äh, lasse ich mir gefallen, es ist sinnvoll.
Next.
Okay, was gibt das?
Moment, wenn man die Chipstüte umdreht und sie ist offen, dann fallen die Chips raus.
Nein, ernsthaft?
Schwerkraft OP, sage ich da nur.
Huge brain.
Hä?
Was, was genau will er uns damit sagen?
Okay, da gucken wir uns jetzt mal den Hack an.
Leute, ist das überhaupt ein deutsches Video oder ist das einfach ein Video?
Meißmehl, okay, nee, doch, ist doch in deutsch.
Weil diese, diese, diese Lifehack-Channels habe ich auch schon gesehen, dass die einfach englischsprachige Videos nehmen, deutschen Text drüber machen und, ähm, dann ist gut.
Was soll denn das geben, wenn es fertig ist?
Nee, jetzt ist es zu, jetzt fällt es ja auch nicht mehr raus.
Hä?
Oh, es geht mit der ab.
Moment, was?
Ach, ich glaube, jetzt habe ich es, ich glaube, jetzt habe ich es gecheckt, was der uns sagen will.
Nee, also entweder...
Möchte er uns sagen, ähm, so kann man eine Chipstüte wieder richtig verschließen.
Man könnte, man könnte einfach eine Klammer oder so nehmen.
Ähm, ich glaube aber, er möchte uns sagen, so kann man Platz sparen mit einer Chipstüte.
Die Sache ist nur die, dass ja sogar absichtlich Luft in der Chipstüte drin ist, dass die Chips nicht kaputt gehen.
Also es ist ja gar nicht mal so, dass das, dass die Chipstüte Scamars ist, sondern die Chipstüte hat Luft drin, dass die Chips nicht kaputt gehen.
Also da haben sich die Chipstüten her, die Chipshersteller sogar...
Da war schon was bei gedacht.
Alter, gibt das, gibt das jetzt hier Monkartos oder was?
Was gibt das hier jetzt?
Nasefrei in 10 Sekunden.
Was?
Ja, genau.
Drück, drück den Scheiß...
Oh Gott, ey, das...
Ich will es mir gar nicht angucken, gell.
Ich gucke mir das nicht an, ey.
Geh fort.
Ich meine, der Scheiß muss raus, ja, der da so läuft, wenn man erkältet ist.
Und wie sinnvoll das ist, den Krams dann irgendwo in irgendwelche Ritzen...
Zu pusten, dass er nicht mehr richtig abläuft, ist wahrscheinlich das kontraproduktivste, was du irgendwie machen kannst.
Dann sollte man sich im Zweifelsfall schon wenigstens irgendwie Nasenspray reinmachen, wobei das auch nicht gesund ist.
Das hilft wenigstens mal kurzzeitig.
Aber ich mache das eigentlich auch so gut wie nie, wenn es nicht unbedingt sein muss.
Einfach mal zwei, drei Tage laufen lassen und gut ist.
Ich meine, was willst du machen?
Dann nimmst du halt ein Taschentuch, sonst was.
Ordentliche Box voll und gut ist.
Ich meine, man stirbt nicht dran.
Das ist unangenehm.
Und jedes Mal, wenn man erkältet war und dann ist es wieder gut, vergisst man instant, wie scheiße es ist, erkältet zu sein.
Aber dann ist es...
Ich meine, man stirbt ja nicht dran.
Nummer neun.
Okay, also es kam mal als wie...
Schneidende Paprika.
Okay.
Good job.
Okay, jetzt kriegen wir gezeigt, wie man Schuhe bindet.
Okay.
Ja, warum nicht?
Ja, wenn man die Schuhe...
Wenn einem die drei Sekunden, die das normal dauert, zu langsam sind und man so den krassen Hexor-Schuhbinder machen will, dann ist das ja schon...
Vielleicht ist der Tipp wenigstens mal ganz okay.
So, was kommt als nächstes?
Rechnen auf Japanisch.
Okay.
Das ist nur für Leute mit großem Gehirn.
Ach, jetzt check ich das.
Du malst jede Zahl auf und dann zählst du die Punkte quasi.
Mit diesem...
Wo sie sich überschneiden.
Wobei ich glaube nicht, dass das Japanisch ist.
So was...
Fast alles, was irgendwie auch nur ansatzweise geometrisch aussieht, ist Griechisch.
Die Griechen waren da echt erfinderisch, was das angeht.
Geht das nur von 0 bis 3?
Von 1 bis 3?
Oder geht das auch mit mehr?
Von der Idee her würde ich sagen, geht das auch mit mehr.
Das Problem dürfte nur sein, wenn man das mit größeren Zahlen macht.
Also mit höheren einzelnen Zahlen.
Dass man dann viel, viel mehr Striche braucht und irgendwie das überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr ergibt.
Okay, machen sie es nämlich auch wieder nur mit 1, 2, 3, 3, 2, 1.
Man lernt das in japanischen Schulen.
Aber ich sag mal, easy Taschenrechner, easy life.
Kann ja auch Kalk auf dem Calculator auf dem Handy sein.
Ich mein, das ist schon recht elegant.
Oder einfach Kopf rechnen, genau.
Die machen das aber immer nur mit 1, 2 und 3?
Oder, oder, ja.
Aber wahrscheinlich wird das einfach zu groß, wenn man das mit mehr Zahlen macht, mit Höhe, mit Größeren.
Guckt wieder nur, wieder nur.
1, immer nur 0 bis 3.
Oder alternativ wisst ihr, was ihr auch machen könnt.
Wenn, ähm, wollte ich gerade sagen, ähm, choose by name.
Wenn ihr, wenn ihr irgendwie was, so große Dinger, die eh keiner nachrechnen kann.
Keine, die eh keiner nachrechnen kann.
Dass ihr dann sagt, so ungefähr so die erste Zahl.
Die erste Zahl hier ist irgendwas mit, mit 4 wahrscheinlich, so, weil, ne?
2, 3, 3, so irgendwas, irgendwas mit 4 oder sowas vorne vielleicht.
Dass man dann irgendwie sagt, keine Ahnung, äh, 45.392.
Und 90% der Leute glauben dir das dann.
Wobei ist das, ne, das reicht überhaupt nicht für ne 4 vorne, ne?
Dann sagst du dann irgendwie 38.427.
Und dann sagen, sagen alle, boah, boah, hast du aber schnell den Kopf gerechnet.
Was kommt raus? Ok, was mit ner 3?
Ah, ok, ja.
39.430.
39.483.
Aber das kann eh keiner so schnell nachrechnen.
Ok, das ist ja langweilig.
Also außer den, außer den Schuhe-Bin-Trick fand ich davon jetzt nix irgendwie sonderlich toll.
Langweilig.
Wirst du eigentlich mal Google, achso, wir können ja mal in das PPGA-Board gucken.
Weißt du, ob man die Auto-Übersetzung von YouTube-Titeln irgendwie verhindern kann?
Ja, ich glaub, du kannst Google auf Englisch umstellen.
Das geht hier unten irgendwie, ne, äh, fuck.
Wo ging das?
Man konnte Google auf Englisch umstellen.
WTF?
Was krieg ich denn da empfohlen?
Früher war das unten auf der Seite.
Da konnte man die Sprache auswählen.
Das geht aber nimmer, weil Endless-Scroll.
Ach, hier, Sprache.
Ja, du kannst die Sprache auf Englisch stellen und dann ist, dann sollte das aufhören zu übersetzen.
Ink-Cardridges are scam.
Ne, solange sie funktionieren, sind sie kein Scam.
Sie sind, sie sind auf jeden Fall zu teuer, die Original-Cartridges.
Deswegen kaufe ich auch nur noch Drittanbieter, äh, Druckerpatronen.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch?
Wirst du Google Stadia ausprobieren?
Ich guck's mir vielleicht mal an, aber ich weiß jetzt schon, dass das für mich nix ist.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das wieder so ein typisches Google-Ding wird,
mit Riesentamtam angekündigt und dann ein halbes Jahr später eingestellt, weil's sacken wird.
Man darf ja nicht vergessen, ähm, die können ja alle nicht zaubern.
Also sei's, das ist ja auch nix Neues.
Das erste, was ich damals ausprobiert hab, war OnLive hieß das, glaub ich.
Das war 2015 oder 14 und sind schon ewig her.
Und die haben das im Prinzip auch so probiert.
Ja, du, du hattest quasi dort den Server stehen, mit Grafikkarten drin, da ist dein Game drauf gelaufen und es hat zu dir gestreamt.
Mittlerweile ist natürlich die Internetanbindung bei den Leuten daheim besser.
Und, ähm, Google hat natürlich auch mehr Infrastruktur deutschlandweit stehen, als vielleicht so ein einzelner Anbieter.
Allerdings!
Ja.
Allerdings kann auch Google nicht zaubern.
Also, auch bei Google ist die Lichtgeschwindigkeit Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Und auch bei Google braucht es ne gewisse Weile, bis was, ähm, in den Rechner reinkommt und wieder rauskommt.
Ja.
Es dauert auch ne gewisse Weile, bis von eurem Controller was dahin übertragen wird.
Also, die können alle nicht zaubern.
Und dementsprechend denke ich,
dass diese ganze Remote-Gaming-Geschichte einzig und allein für den Casual-Spieler relevant ist.
Natürlich sind das die meisten.
Allerdings sogar die, die Casual-mäßig, sagen wir mal Battlefield spielen oder sowas,
sogar die werden das schon nicht über einen Streaming-Service machen.
Das werden so Leute sein, die einmal im Jahr das neue Assassin's Creed spielen oder so.
Die spielen das dann halt über Google Stadia vom Tablet mit Bluetooth-Controller oder sowas.
Allerdings Leute, die, die, die, die einen gewissen Anspruch haben an, ähm, so, Responsiveness und,
und spätestens mal Multiplayer spielen, hört auch der Casual auf, sowas über, über Streaming-Anbieter zu, zu spielen.
Wo gibt es deine PPGA-Board-Soundfiles?
Na neun, neun, das PPGA-Board ist mein, mein, mein Chat, Chat-Programm, ja.
Was du meinst, ist das, das, das Meme-Board. Das da meinst du.
Ha, das hört sich so dumm an.
Äh, die gibt's gar nicht.
Das ist, ähm, das ist einmal, das ist einmal die in Windows eingebaute Text-to-Speech
und das ist irgendeine japanische Text-to-Speech-API, die wir im Hintergrund verwenden.
Die gibt's nirgendwo, die Files, die werden, die werden erzeugt hier.
Es gibt, sind keine Files, das ist von, von japanischen Text-to-Speech-API.
Man kann auch Files rein, rein machen, ja.
Hier zum Beispiel der Camera-Dude, ne.
Mom, get the camera. Den, äh, das ist so ein Waff, ein Waff-File, was ich reingezogen hab.
Aber die anderen Sachen sind halt dynamisch erzeugt von der Text-to-Speech-Engine.
Voice-Text, genau, Voice-Text ist es.
Ja, also so viel, so viel zum Thema, äh, Stadia.
Ähm, ich probier's mal aus, aber die können auch nicht zaubern.
Das hatten wir schon.
Dann sind die deutschen Titel auch in Englisch.
Ach, man kann mehrere Sprachen dazu, wusste ich gar nicht.
Ich hab eh alles auf Englisch stehen, immer.
Ich finde, dass Google ihre Projekte nicht gut weiterführt.
Oh ja, das finde ich auch.
Hab seit zwei Jahren Google Home und seitdem ich...
Ja, ja, das ist das Problem.
Habt ihr das mit Nest mitbekommen?
Die hatten, ähm, das sind so, so Thermostat-Dinger.
Sowas da, so Dinger.
Ähm, was vor allem in den USA recht beliebt war.
Und die hatten bisher, die hatten vor, die hatten in der, die ganze Zeit schon Probleme, dass, ähm, die ab, dass die Nest-Cloud öfters mal ausgefallen ist.
Und, ähm, wenn die Nest-Cloud ausgefallen ist, konnten die Leute ihre Heizung nicht mehr einstellen.
Was, was schon echt übelster Pepega-Scheiß ist, ja.
Wenn du deine eigene Heizung nicht mehr einstellen kannst, weil, weil Nest grad nicht, äh, erreichbar ist.
Zumindest Google hat sich gedacht, wir setzen der Sache jetzt noch die, die Krone auf.
Und zwar schalten wir die Nest-API einfach ab.
Das heißt, alle, die irgendwelche Nest-Integrationen haben, alle, die irgendwelche Heimautomatisierungs-Sachen haben, alle, die damit irgendwas machen, können das nicht mehr machen, weil Google gesagt hat, ne.
Nest-API kommt weg.
Ist halt...
Richtig.
Ja.
Deswegen kauf ich mir so ein Kram auch nicht.
Und ja, wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, ich, ich finde auch, dass Google, ähm, viele Sachen macht, auch mit riesen TamTam macht, und im Nachhinein die Sachen aber irgendwie merkwürdig oder halbherzig macht.
Ich mein, guckt euch Google Plus an.
Google Plus war von Anfang an ein absoluter Bullshit.
Also, ne, stimmt nicht.
Nicht Google Plus an sich.
Über Google Plus an sich kann man sich streiten.
Ähm, die Zwangsintegration mit YouTube zum Beispiel war übelster Bullshit.
Das war das bescheuertste, was die auf YouTube je gemacht haben.
Bescheuerter als sogar diese, ja, sogar die Designänderung.
Aber Google Plus Zwangsintegration war der größte Bullshit ever.
Du konntest von heute auf morgen nicht mal ordentliche Nachrichten schreiben.
Ähm, kann man dich irgendwie direkt anschreiben?
Ja, kannst du machen.
Du kannst mir eine Business-E-Mail, also falls das, weiß ich nicht, was du, was du, was du, äh, was du schreiben willst, ähm, kannst du mir eine Business-E-Mail schreiben.
Meine Business-E-Mail findest du, äh, hier unter, auf meinem YouTube-Channel und zwar unter Kanalinfo.
Da, kannst du dann draufklicken und dann siehst du die.
YouTube-Channel ist verlinkt auf der Profilseite.
Huge.
Ähm, falls es aber um irgendwelche, äh, technische Fragen geht oder so, dann hau es in den Stream-Chat.
Weil dafür ist das ja nicht gedacht.
Ähm, by the, by the way, ist Buchstaben kopieren so ein Tick von dir? Mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1.
Ah, ne, passt, passt, ja, hat schon, Leute haben es schon verlinkt.
Willst du dir mal wieder ein Postfach anlegen? Ne, das geht ja in Deutschland nicht so ohne weiteres.
Ohne, ohne echten Namen und sowas.
Wenn schon, lass ich das dann mal vielleicht irgendwann über, übers Netzwerk machen oder so.
Eigentlich, eigentlich nicht.
Boah, das ist irgendwie ein bisschen kaputt.
Wir müssen uns, wenn eine Störung ist laut SLA, einmal von Berliner Frankfurt teleportieren.
Ja, SLAs, das stimmt schon, haben teilweise oftmals mit der Realität wenig zu tun.
Kommt auch immer nur im Ernstfall drauf an, ob sich einer verklagt deswegen.
Ja, ja, und Zuschauer habe ich tatsächlich schon, äh, bin ich tatsächlich schon über den Weg gelaufen.
Ähm, einmal auf der Gamescom natürlich, da ist das öfters passiert, was das Leute erkannt haben.
Am lustigsten war es, wo wir Battlefield, damals, was war das, Battlefield Hardline Probe gespielt haben.
Auf der, auf der Gamescom.
Und, das, die, die, die haben noch, in Hardline gab es noch diesen, diesen, ich nenne es mal diesen Rainbow Six Modus.
Wo man 5 gegen 5 gespielt hat, verteidigen und die fänden diesen CS Modus, diesen Fake CS Modus.
Und, da waren wir halt, äh, zusammengewürfelt im Team.
Und ich hab dann halt gesagt auf einmal, irgendwie so mitten in der Runde, hab gesagt, ey Jungs, wir sucken übelst oder so.
Und dann kam dann danach jemand zu mir und hat gefragt, sag mal, bist du der, bist du Max von, MaxFPS von YouTube?
Haha.
Das hat sich zu nach Max angehört, wo ich gesagt hab, wir sucken, Alter.
Wir sucken, ey.
Kam aber, kam aber angestellt, ja.
Ähm, und, auf der Arbeit haben mich auch schon 2 Azubis.
Enttarnt.
Ja.
Aber, gut, wenn es denn nichts Wildes.
Revealed, genau, na, Revealed wurde er hier.
Revealed wurde ich doch schon, wo ist es?
Hier.
Revealed wurde ich doch schon damals, 2013.
2013 in dem Video, ja.
Ja.
Da weiß man es.
Das, das, seit da weiß man es, ja.
Direkt, liegt.
Ich mein, ich erkenne mich da drauf, ja.
Aber jemand anderes nicht.
Bist du aber ziemlich verzerrt.
Alter, willst du mich beleidigen oder was?
Ich seh halt nun mal so aus.
Anzeige ist raus.
Na, was haben wir sonst noch für Fragen?
Meinung zu Google One.
Ist Google One nicht das Smartphone von denen?
Ne, was war Google One?
Ach, ach.
Das, das, das, das, das Laufwerk.
Moment.
Google One?
Ne, das ist wieder was anderes, oder?
War, war One nicht Microsoft?
OneDrive?
Das war doch Microsoft.
Sag mal.
Können die sich mal ordentliche Namen ausdenken?
In dem einen TV-Video von denen sieht man das nicht ganz gut.
Es gibt ein paar Videos, wo man das nicht ganz gut sieht.
Es gibt sogar, es gibt sogar irgendwo ein Video.
Es gibt sogar irgendwo ein Video vom, vom Battle, von, von dem Battlefield 1 Event, wo ich, wo ich in der Ecke stehe und, und man mich komplett sieht, aber es hat halt keiner gecheckt, dass ich das bin.
Warum, warum nennen, warum nennen die das Google One und warum heißt das OneDrive?
Das ist schon wieder Verwirrung vorprogrammiert.
Google One ist, ist das neu oder was?
Oder, die, die haben doch schon, also Google, Google Cloud Speicher gibt's doch schon eine Weile.
Was gibt's denn da?
Jede Menge Platz.
Wie viel?
Ach hier.
Oh, das ist aber ziemlich günstig.
Na, wobei.
Wobei.
Lass mal überlegen.
20 Euro im Jahr.
Was sind denn so die, was sind denn so.
Warte mal, was, ähm.
Was kosten das da?
Die sind doch recht beliebt für, für Backup-Geschichten.
Unbegrenzte Datensicherung.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Äh.
Es gab, es gab doch auch so einen ZFS-Backup-Anbieter.
Was hat denn das da gekostet?
AirSync, genau.
War das das?
Was kosten denn hier die Gigabyte?
Jetzt sind wir voll, ah da, Pricing.
Das ist nicht richtig beschrieben.
Ich kann das gar nicht richtig einschätzen, ob 100G mittlerweile gut oder schlecht sind für 2 Euro im Monat.
Bauchgefühl würde ich sagen, das ist eigentlich relativ günstig.
Aber so wirklich sicher bin ich mir nicht.
Und die Sache ist die, wie kann man drauf zugreifen?
Geht das nur offiziell über die App?
Geht das nur über das Webinterface?
Oder kann man sogar sich das Laufwerk irgendwie unter Linux mounten oder so?
Das wäre natürlich richtig geil, wenn man das als Netzlaufwerk verwenden könnte.
Weil da kann man auch ordentlich Backups drauf machen.
Was, Musikrip?
Geht doch noch alles.
Außer, dass die Musik sackt.
Also 2 Euro für 100G ist dagegen schlecht, okay.
Wir gucken mal, was man aktuell bei Hetzner Server Auktion bekommen würde.
An Speicherplatz für ein System, wenn man das selbst bauen will.
Das ist nicht das Billigste, ist klar.
Aber schauen wir mal, was würde man so aktuell kriegen?
Haben wir mal Preis im Monat, sagen wir mal 20 Euro.
Yes, ich agree, ich agree.
ADD-Size.
Kann man das jetzt irgendwie...
Irgendwie sieht die Seite anders aus, als das letzte Mal.
Datacenter ist mir egal.
Auktionen.
Ähm, Capacity.
Konnte man das nicht früher mal sortieren?
Also 6TB für 30 Euro im Monat.
Das ist natürlich jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn, ne?
Allerdings...
Na doch, das ist okay.
Guckt mal.
6TB für 30...
Das ist billiger.
Das ist billiger als Google Drive.
Also wenn sogar die Hetzner Server Auktion billiger ist als Google Drive.
Na, also hier kriegst du für 3 Euro...
Sagen wir mal so, wenn man das jetzt mal verschieben würde, ja.
Dann kosten 600GB 3 Euro.
Was immer noch viel günstiger ist als bei Google.
Gut, man muss sich selbst drum kümmern.
Aber unterm Strich ist das hier eigentlich in der Regel teurer als bei einem Storage-Anbieter.
Das heißt, das lohnt sich nicht so richtig.
Ist eigentlich nicht so...
Nicht so tolle.
Aber vor einer Weile gab's doch...
Gab's doch die Möglichkeit, dass man sich nen...
Nen YouTube-Premium-Account oder irgendwie so nen...
So nen...
So nen Family-Account oder irgendwie sowas war das doch macht.
Wo man dann quasi noch andere User mit anmelden kann.
Und dann war das doch angeblich richtig billig.
Erinnere mich da irgendwie dran.
Insomniac-Dude, ich würd mir erst mal überlegen, ob du wirklich 300GB Backup hast.
Also ob das wirklich das Notwendige ist.
Ähm...
Und dann müsste ich mal gucken, weil ich bin aktuell auch nicht mehr auf dem Laufenden, was gute Server-Anbieter angeht.
Hetzner Storage-Boxes.
Stimmt, was gibt's denn da?
Na, so geil ist das jetzt alle, oder?
Terabyte für 10 Euro?
Ganz schön teuer.
Naja gut, okay, Moment.
Man hat ja auch Zugriff per SSH, per RSYNC, per...
Dafür ist es gar nicht mal übel.
Das ist fix und fertig und du kannst direkt mit ordentlichen Tools drauf synchen und backuppen.
Kannst WebDAV mounten.
Kannst Borg backuppen.
Kannst Samba mounten und so.
Dafür ist es gar nicht schlecht.
Ich mein, okay, 10 Euro ist schon mal recht ordentlich, ja.
Da müsste ich mich mal schlau machen, was es aktuell für gute Anbieter gibt.
Früher haben sie immer auf Reddit und so den hier empfohlen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das jetzt aktuell ist hier.
Simple Pricing, Unlimited Data.
Früher haben sie den hier immer für Backup empfohlen auf Reddit.
Habe ich aber nie verwendet.
Samba mount über das Internet.
Naja, YOLO.
Was kostet denn das hier?
Personal Backup.
Ja.
6 Euro im Monat.
Und wie viel Speicher ist das?
Sieht das jemand, wie viel Speicher das jetzt ist?
Achso, das ist auch ganz cool.
Wenn man Restoren muss, dann kann man es sich per USB schicken lassen.
Oder per Platte zuschicken lassen.
Dropbox 2TB, 10 Euro im Monat.
Ja, das ist doch okay.
Also ich weiß noch, dass sie den auf Reddit früher immer empfohlen haben.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt aber nicht genau warum, wenn ich mir das so angucke.
6 Euro im Monat, pro Computer.
Ist das Unlimited?
Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Unlimited für 6, 6, 6 Dollar im Monat.
Das wäre natürlich echt gut, ja.
Also ich meine, Unlimited ist wahrscheinlich, ne?
Unlimited.
Also so Fake Unlimited.
Genauso Unlimited wie Vodafone.
Vodafone, habt ihr das?
Unlimited.
Ähm.
Vodafone hat doch letztens wieder irgendwelche Leute rausgeschmissen, weil sie Unlimited wörtlich genommen haben.
Die...
Ach ja, Amazon.
Amazon hatte ja auch mal...
War das nicht O2?
Das kann doch O2 gewesen sein.
Es könnten doch einfach beide gewesen sein.
Es könnten doch einfach beide gewesen sein, weil das traue ich jedem Anbieter zu.
Freenet?
Ist das nicht mittlerweile...
Freenet ist doch irgendwas anderes.
Gehört doch irgend...
Freenet, Freenet ist doch, ist doch, ist doch 1&1, oder?
War das Freenet hier?
Ach ja, hier, das da.
Freenet.
König, Kunden mit hohem Datenverbrauch.
Ich denke, es wäre halt mal sinnvoll, dass man, dass man regelt, was Flatrate eigentlich bedeutet.
Weil aktuell schreiben sie alle Flatrate drauf und es ist im Endeffekt keine.
Es wäre doch für alle Beteiligten besser zu wissen, was Sache ist, ja?
Und wenn zu mir einer sagt, hey, du hast ein 500 Gigabyte Tarif, dann weiß ich, es sind 500 Gigabyte.
Und ich weiß auch, dass es mir reicht.
Aber das wäre echt gut.
Also wenn die, wenn die Unlimited auch halbwegs ernst macht.
Nein, für 6 Euro im Monat kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Ich weiß aber halt auch nicht, ob man dismounten kann richtig.
Wie, wie, wie das funktioniert.
Das Offsite Backup steht ja bei mir auch schon länger auf dem Plan, dass ich mir mal was Gescheites überlege.
Aber ich habe noch nichts Gescheites gemacht in der Richtung.
Aktuell geht mein Backup auf meine Kiste hier, die hinter mir steht.
Mit den 3x, 3x10 Terabyte Platten drin, also 20 Terabyte, 20 Terabyte ZFS Rate 1 ist das.
Und da habe ich genug Speicherplatz, mehr als ich überhaupt irgendwie brauche hier.
Und da mache ich meine Backups drauf.
Und ich lösche ja die Dateien auch nicht bei mir irgendwie jetzt auf dem Rechner.
Das heißt, ich habe die dann eh immer mehrfach.
Und die ganz wichtigen Sachen habe ich sogar über Nextcloud gesynct.
So mein, mein Keypass, Keypass Passwort File und so Zeug.
Homewell.
Ja, das stimmt.
Allerdings will man die Platten aus dem RZ gar nicht unbedingt daheim haben.
Weil die, die ausgemustert werden im RZ, die sind meistens nicht die größten und nicht das, was man daheim im Nass haben will.
Dann hast du dann irgendwelche ollen 15K SAS Platten mit, keine Ahnung, was haben die so 320G oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich weiß nicht, was die Dinger da haben, die man gerade ausmistet.
Das will man eigentlich daheim gar nicht unbedingt haben.
Das muss man unbedingt im Nass verwenden.
Wobei RZ Rabatt ist tatsächlich nicht verkehrt.
Ich habe auch schon ein paar ausgemusterte Sachen hier bei mir eingebaut.
Zum Beispiel die Quad Port Intel Netzwerkkarte ist bei uns aus dem RZ.
Die wurde ausgemustert.
Und dann habe ich noch zwei Dual Port Netzwerkkarten, die wurden aus dem RZ ausgemustert.
Und noch ein paar Glasfaserkabel für 10G Netzwerk.
Die haben wir auch ausgemustert.
Da habe ich auch ein paar abgreifen können.
Ausrufezeichen PC, tatsächlich so ein Kommando haben wir, wusste ich gar nicht.
Ist das überhaupt der richtige PC?
Ja, ist der richtige PC.
Interessant.
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass wir ein Kommando für einen aktuellen PC haben.
Meinung zu Facebook Libra, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Okay.
Schon mitbekommen, man kann jetzt über Local Host auf WSL zugreifen.
Hä?
Ich konnte schon immer über Local Host auf WSL zugreifen.
Oder was, was meinst du damit jetzt?
Bist du ein Fan von Windows WSL oder doch eher Dual Boot?
Weder noch.
Ich finde Windows WSL geht auf jeden Fall in die richtige Richtung.
Und Dual Boot, also dauert aber noch ein bisschen, bis man das ordentlich verwenden kann.
Du kannst zum Beispiel nichts gescheiten mounten und sowas.
Copy und Paste ist auch so eine Sache für sich.
Schön finde ich es nicht.
Dual Boot, finde ich, sackt, weil Dual Boot zu lang dauert.
Deswegen ist das Beste, was man machen kann, einfach Windows mit Linux VM.
Beste.
Windows mit Linux VM.
Einfach auf einem Desktop die Linux VM und auf dem anderen Desktop Windows.
Das ist das Beste, was es gibt.
Das ist dann auch ein vollständiges Linux, ohne dass man WSL braucht.
Einfach besser.
ROX abonniert Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön, nice.
Das hört sich so geil an.
Moment, das hier.
Ähm.
Wie lange sind wir jetzt schon on?
Eineinhalb Stunden.
Also wie gesagt, kein Dual Boot.
Quatschna, Twitch Prime.
Übrigens, dankeschön Quatschna.
Auch hier, nice.
Ultra nice.
Ähm.
Was ich gerade sagen wollte.
Wenn ihr auch, jetzt geht es aber ab hier.
PsiNorm420, dankeschön.
Nice.
Was für eine VM-Karte.
Was kannst du empfehlen, vor allem bei Workstation?
Es geht allerdings auch mit VirtualBox.
Geht theoretisch auch mit Hyper-V, würde ich mal sagen.
Habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Ähm.
Aber, vor allem bei Workstation.
Ist für mich die rundeste Lösung unter Windows.
Kannst du die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen?
Die Musik ist eigentlich ziemlich leise.
Die kann sich bloß irgendwie nicht entscheiden, ob sie leise oder laut ist.
Guck, jetzt geht es wieder voll ab.
The fuck?
Warum Vengaboys?
Was hat das denn mit Vengaboys zu tun?
Achso, das war das, was ich davor laufen hatte.
So, jetzt habe ich mal ein bisschen leiser gemacht.
Jetzt müsste es passen.
Was muss denn das Meme-Tool?
Ah, na, nicht unbedingt.
Wobei.
Könnte man eigentlich machen.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Ob das funktioniert.
Also.
Da müssen wir YouTube Download machen.
YouTube Download.
Ähm.
Vielleicht mal zeigen, wie man das macht.
Minus F.
Kann man sich das Format anzeigen lassen.
So, und jetzt wollen wir haben.
Das Format will ich eigentlich nur.
Nur die Audiodatei haben.
Davon.
Nur die Audiodatei.
So krasser.
Hacks or Dricks jetzt.
So, nur die Audiodatei runterladen.
Von dem Video.
Was, 140?
Warum 140?
Ah, 140.
Ja, ihr habt Recht.
140.
Will ich haben, nicht 100.
Ja, weil.
Warum will ich 140 haben?
Weil 140 ist 130k Audio.
Und das andere ist nur 50k Audio.
Das suckt.
Besser.
Jetzt können wir YouTube Video runterladen.
Also, jetzt haben wir uns nur die Audiospur vom YouTube Video runtergeladen.
Können wir jetzt mal testen, ob das funktioniert.
VLC aufmachen.
Das Ganze einfach.
Jetzt sollte das eigentlich.
Wow, Alter.
Funktioniert.
Und jetzt haben wir FFmpeg.
Wir konvertieren das einfach zu.
Gbated.
Waff.
Minus i.
So, und jetzt.
Gehen wir in mein Board.
Gbated.
Jetzt gehen wir in mein Board und ziehen das da rein.
Und sagen Upload.
Und hoffen, dass es funktioniert, weil die Datei ziemlich groß ist.
Hat das jetzt funktioniert?
Ich glaube, die Datei ist zu groß.
Ich glaube, weil es Gbated schon gibt.
Oh ne, die Datei ist zu groß.
Es buggt rum, wenn die Datei so groß ist.
Geht nicht.
Darf ich vielleicht als mp3?
Darf man das als mp3?
Geht es vielleicht als mp3?
Ne, die Datei.
Es ist einfach zu lang.
Das geht ja 10 Minuten.
Ich muss das kürzen.
Ich muss das auf jeden Fall kürzen.
Weil sonst spielt er 10 Minuten.
Sonst spielt er 10 Minuten Gbated ab.
Ich muss das kürzer machen.
Wie macht man das mit FFmpeg?
Skip? Irgendwie, ne?
Only 10 seconds.
Ja.
Skip.
Beste.
So, und jetzt haben wir.
Gbated.
3.
Geht nur 10 Sekunden.
Sollte es besser funktionieren, denke ich.
Ah!
You've got Gbated.
Jetzt funktioniert es!
Siehste?
Habe ich doch keinen Mist programmiert.
You've got Gbated.
Ne, keine Animation.
Da kann ich irgendwas anderes einblenden zu.
Ja, aber.
Das haben wir so ein bisschen sidetracken lassen bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Mach das noch etwas leiser.
Das ist leider nicht supported.
Das müsste ich mit FFmpeg irgendwie leiser machen.
Ich hab hier noch kein...
Ich müsste hier einen Audioslider noch einbauen.
Ähm.
Wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie formulier ich das denn jetzt?
Make sound louder.
Was ist denn das Gegenteil von louder?
More silence.
Decrease.
Aha.
Das ist...
FFmpeg kann alles.
Half volume.
FFmpeg kann einfach alles.
Okay, löschen wir das mal wieder.
Debated ist weg.
Also ich muss sagen, mein Memeboard funktioniert mittlerweile echt ganz okay.
Hier.
Debated 4.
Gucken wir mal, ob es jetzt leiser ist.
Ist das jetzt leiser?
Ja, ist leiser, ne?
Ist leiser.
Hast du nochmal was?
Hast du noch was dran gemacht?
Nö.
Nö, nö.
Ist immer noch die...
Die...
Die Version von vor einem Jahr oder so.
Das ist allerdings nicht so ganz einheitlich laut.
Na gut.
Ähm.
Genug rumgebastelt.
Hab ich noch was offen?
Das stimmt.
Da weiß ich allerdings vom besten Willen nicht, wie ich das in FFmpeg gescheit mache.
Müssen wir erstmal suchen danach.
Ne, hab ich nix dran gemacht.
Wie gesagt, vor allem eine Workstation würde ich empfehlen.
Es macht für mich den rundesten Eindruck.
Hat...
Äh...
Hat das einen Grund, warum du nicht Wasser kühlst?
Wirklich, den Grund hat das nicht.
Ne.
Ich hab mich früher nie so richtig an Wasserkühlung herangetraut.
Mittlerweile ist das ja kein Ding, wenn du dir so ein All-in-One-Ding holst.
Da muss man sich ja nicht mehr groß anpassen.
Da muss man sich ja nicht randrauen.
Das ist ja fix und fertig.
Ähm.
Und bis jetzt hab ich einfach noch nix...
Hab ich so nicht ausprobiert.
Also es hat keinen Grund, warum ich nicht Wasser kühle.
Also keinen rationalen, erklärbaren Grund irgendwie.
Achso, für die Hintergrundmusik.
Ja, gut.
Das ist aber halt nicht die Hintergrundmusik.
Das ist halt das komplette Desktop-Audio.
Also auch Spielesound und so.
Was?
Why you shouldn't...
Watercool your PC?
Von Linus Technips.
Da hat er wahrscheinlich wieder irgendwelche komischen Dinger gemacht.
Es gibt ganz viele Leute, die ihren PC wasserkühlen.
Ich kenne auch jede Menge mittlerweile.
Die meisten, würde ich fast sagen, haben es zumindest schon mal ausprobiert, die ich kenne.
Die halt auch technikinteressiert sind.
Ist das Kompilieren in einer VM nicht auch langsamer als nativ Linux laufen zu lassen?
Naja.
Theoretisch schon.
Praktisch ist das keinen großen Unterschied.
Also, CPU-Leistung in einer VM ist ziemlich nah an dem dran, was in deinem Host auch möglich ist.
Der einzige Unterschied ist, dass du dir oftmals deine VM nicht die kompletten Ressourcen zur Verfügung stellst.
Also beispielsweise für meine VM habe ich ja auch hier eingestellt, dass ihr nur zwei CPUs von sechs möglichen CPUs kriegt.
Dann ist es natürlich langsamer.
Aber wenn du der VM...
Deine...
Wenn du der...
Sag mal, wenn du der VM vier Kerne gibst und dein Host kompiliert mit vier Kernen, dann ist der Unterschied nicht sonderlich groß zwischen der VM und wenn du es direkt auf dem Host machst.
So, aber Leute, ich wollte mir noch den neuesten Super Mario World Speedrun World Record angucken.
Nämlich erst einen Monat her, habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Übelst nice.
Alter, der atmet aber ganz schön laut.
Moment.
Erstmal Sound ausmachen.
Ähm, da wir gerade beim Kompilieren sind, was hältst du denn vom neuen N-Gen sinnvoll?
Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ach so, Moment.
Ich habe mich verlesen.
Nicht vom neuen Tool N-Gen.
Ähm, ich überlege, ist das dieses Documentation Generator Ding?
Nee, das ist was anderes, ne?
Dann kann ich dir dazu nichts sagen.
Und wenn ich Linux in einer VM auf dem Laptop laufen lasse, dann zieht das viel Strom oder...
Nö, warum?
Sollte das viel Strom ziehen?
Das zieht Strom, wenn du was machst in deiner VM.
VM bei 14 oder 50 ist das Neueste.
Wird das Neueste nehmen.
So, Speedrun gucken.
Also hier, Speedrun von...
Nicht, dass wir uns jetzt hier mit fremden Federn schmücken.
Das ist von Green Death Flavor.
Von vor einem Monat ungefähr entstanden.
Den wollte ich mir schon die ganze Zeit mal angucken.
Half-Life Speedruns sind auch übelst krass, ja.
Ich gucke aber Mario World Sachen gerne, weil...
Da kommt es so krass auf, wie nennen sie das immer, Execution an.
Also, die resetten ja teilweise schon, wenn sie einen Frame zu spät gesprungen sind und sowas.
Ich meine, das erste Level ist noch relativ easy.
Allerdings halt nicht so, wie die das ausführen, ja.
Jetzt kommt gleich durch die Wand geklippe.
Jetzt klippen sie gleich durch die Wand.
Machen sie nicht.
Wurde hier nicht immer durch die Wand geklippt sonst?
Ich dachte, die sind immer...
Ich dachte, man klippt hier nochmal.
Ah, er redet.
Ist ja auch logisch, ist ja auch sein Channel.
Ich dachte, man klippt da durch die Wand.
Ah.
Ich meine, das ist schon übelst nice.
Und das sind auch die easy Levels, ne.
Ach stimmt, das ist bei Any% ja, hast du recht.
Ich meine, die ersten zwei Levels, die würde ich mir auch noch zutrauen.
Ja, dass ich die ordentlich hinkriege.
Aber danach hört es auf.
Wobei das...
Das geht auch noch irgendwie.
Aber selbst da kommt es halt wahrscheinlich echt drauf an,
dass du so nach dem Motto, beim richtigen Frame zur richtigen Zeit abspringst.
Ich kenne mich von dem Hintergrund her, von der Technik her,
bei Mario World Speedrun sind sie nicht sonderlich gut aus.
Aber spätestens in der Festung ist dann vorbei, ist dann Schluss.
Also spätestens jetzt ist Schluss mit lustig.
Ich denke auch, dass du die ersten drei Levels nicht allzu viel Zeit rausholen kannst.
Aber hier spätestens.
Hier dürfte jetzt Schluss mit lustig sein.
Warum wurde...
Warum wurde der da nicht gehittet?
Warum wurde der eben nicht gehittet?
Jetzt kommt eine Runde Autoscroller.
Das ist jetzt easy, das würde ich jetzt auch wieder hinkriegen.
Und ich wusste gar nicht, dass man nicht stirbt, wenn man in den Stampfer reinspringt.
Ich meine, das ist halt übelst nice.
Das kriege ich...
Das würde ich nie so hinkriegen.
Den Typ mal einfach so easy wegzusnacken.
Ich weiß noch, wo ich das, wo ich klein war, das erste Mal gespielt habe.
Ich habe da irgendwie gefühlt eine halbe Stunde gespielt.
Bis ich das Viech in der Lava hatte.
This is gonna be the run.
Hat man nicht früh geschrieben, dass es der Uhren ist?
War das nicht früher so gang und gäbe?
Ab jetzt wird es schwieriger.
Ich habe ja schon ein paar 11 Exits, Dings, Runs geguckt.
Die Route ist ja am Anfang immer die gleiche.
Und das nehmen auch alle danach mehr oder weniger die gleiche Route.
Wobei ich gesehen habe, dass...
Das ist jetzt irgendwie eine neue Route.
Die super schwierig sein soll.
Das kriege ich auch noch hin.
Easy.
Übrigens, ich glaube, das hier ist das, was du am Anfang mit Yoshi und der Münze machst.
Wo du im ersten Level von Yoshi runterspringst, dass du hier oben so ein Special Item kriegst.
Das da.
Ich glaube, das ist das rumgeglitsche am Anfang mit Yoshi gewesen, dass du hier oben das Item kriegst.
Es sieht easy aus.
Die Sache ist halt die, wenn du einen Sprung verkackst, kannst du resetten.
Ich meine, allein schon das, dass du das schnell hinkriegst mit dem Schlüssel, das ist schon mal nicht ohne.
Ich denke mal, ab und zu, quasi wenn du dir dann ein Safestand im Emulator machst, ein Level so zu spielen, ist kein Ding.
Allerdings das konstant am Stück so zu spielen, ist halt sicher nicht einfach.
Und daher hätte ich jetzt schon längst mein Cape verloren, weil ich an irgendeinem Geist hängen geblieben wäre.
The fuck?
Das ist so weich, wie die sich bewegen immer.
Das ist übelst nice.
Ich wäre da laufen, an irgendwelchen Blöcken hängen geblieben.
Da siehst du halt schon, dass da teilweise Leute tausend Spielstunden oder so drin haben.
Und da habe ich mir auch richtig schwer getan.
Bei dem Buu, wo ich klein war.
Hallo Nacho Libre.
Ach, man kann da so...
Okay.
Easy.
Jetzt kommen die schweren Levels.
Ja, das würde ich auch hinkriegen.
Das würde ich auch hinkriegen.
Da oben mit dem Yoshi lang zu schwimmen.
Aber muss man den Yoshi nicht füttern?
Ne, der verwendet den Yoshi plus zum schnell schwimmen.
Ich glaube, wenn man den Special Exit haben will, dann muss man den Yoshi füttern.
Aber die Bewegung ist halt so weich, ne?
Da wird nirgendswo hängen geblieben oder irgendwas.
Und man sieht schon, das ist quasi fast optimales Movement.
Was hast du da mal? Sekunde?
Unterschied.
Ja, die einzelnen Sachen sind mit Sicherheit auch nicht so schwierig.
Allerdings das konstant hinzukriegen und am Stück ist wahrscheinlich das Schwierige.
Also die einzelnen Sachen zwischendurch geht schon.
Aber wie gesagt, der Dude muss halt resetten, wenn er einmal hängen bleibt.
Also ich würde es nicht auf die Reihe kriegen.
Mach doch ein bisschen Speedrun Training.
Ich gucke. Ich bin ein Speedrun Gucker.
Ich bin ein Speedrun Gucker.
Ich glaube, zum Selbstspeedrun habe ich nicht die mentale Frustresistenz, die man da so braucht.
Wie ewig ich früher gebraucht habe bei diesem Level.
Der kreiselt sich da einfach mal so durch.
Genau, dafür hat er am Anfang mit Yoshi rumgeklitscht, dass er jetzt die Wolke kriegt.
Stimmt, genau so war das. Ich erinnere mich wieder.
Weil du bist mit der Wolke in dem Fight viel schneller.
Und normalerweise sollst du hier ja keine Wolke haben.
Und normalerweise kannst du auch keine Wolke da in deinem Power-Up-Ding storen.
Das geht nur, wenn du im ersten Level mit Yoshi rumgeklitscht hast.
Wieso verliert er seinen Umhang nicht?
Solange du Spinjumpst, verlierst du deinen Umhang nicht, wenn du getroffen wirst, glaube ich.
Dann kriegst du bloß so einen...
Ne, solange du fliegst, verlierst du deinen Umhang nicht, wenn du getroffen wirst.
Genau, dann wirst du bloß aus dem Fliegen rausgeworfen.
Wow.
Jetzt ist er eskaliert.
Jetzt ist er eskaliert, äh.
Da freut sich einer.
Mario sieht ein bisschen verbackt aus.
Ja, pock.
Der ist voll aus dem Häuschen, äh.
Boah, der eskaliert ja voll.
Der ist, der ist ja fast am Wein, äh.
Aber kann ich verstehen.
Ich mein, ich will nicht...
Guck mal.
Zwei...
2043 Anläufe hat es gebraucht.
Da kann ich verstehen, dass man danach ein bisschen fertig mit den Nerven ist.
Irgendjemand hat geschrieben, Half-Life-Speedruns sind auch übelst krass.
Das stimmt.
Da gab's...
Es gab, glaube ich, auch...
Es gab, glaube ich, auch letztens einen Half-Life-Rekord, wenn ich mich nicht irre.
Genau, vor 14 Tagen.
Ne, doch Scriptless, genau.
Ähm.
Vor 14 Tagen gab's einen neuen...
Das hab ich mitgekriegt, weil ich zufällig im Esa-Stream letztens Half-Life geguckt
hab und da saß halt der Typ mit dem Rekord.
Ist auch übelst heftig.
Ey, es ist übelst heftig, wie Half-Life-Speedruns aussehen.
Ähm.
Das ist echt krass.
Moment, kann man da die Auflösung ein bisschen hoch stellen?
Ah, die Auflösung ein bisschen hoch.
Das ist übelst krass, Half-Life-Speedruns, was ich übrigens auch toll finde, dass die
irgendwie ohne 3D-Beschleunigung spielen, rein ins Software.
Ich mein, guck mal, wie der allein schon durch das erste Level durchsaust.
Und vor allem, dass das Ganze halt nicht hängen bleibt.
Ich glaub, jeder, der Half-Life gespielt hat, Half-Life 1 oder Half-Life 2, ähm, und Half-Life
2 ist das noch viel schlimmer.
Ähm.
Hat das Problem, dass er permanent an irgendeinem Shit hängen bleibt.
Und das ist, generell finde ich, wo man, wo sich halt so richtig gute Speedrunner unterscheiden
von, sagen wir mal, von nicht so guten Speedrunnern und von 715 Casual Gamer, ist halt eindeutig,
wenn du siehst, wie smooth sich die Leute, also wie weich sich die Leute durch die Levels
bewegen.
Da merkst du halt, die haben halt schon Erfahrungen mit, wo halt irgendwie ein Schrank hängt
oder wo irgendwas ist, die dich halt bewegen.
Da wird nicht hängen geblieben, da wird exakt, das ist halt echt nice.
Und das ist ja mein, das ist ja noch quasi Intro, ne.
Vor allem, wie eckig die Dinger in Half-Life ausgeschaut haben damals.
Achso, übrigens, äh, hier, das ist der Speedrunner, Movement is Key, ja, ist so.
Und das siehst du, das siehst du in allen Games.
Was, was die Sachen rausreißt, ist hauptsächlich das Movement.
Bei nahezu allen, bei nahezu allen Spielen.
Ja, genau.
Bei allen Speedruns, die man so sieht, die, also der Unterschied zwischen, zwischen dem
Besten, also den Besten und denen, die danach kommen, ist hauptsächlich, wie sich bewegt
wird in den Games.
Und dazu zählt natürlich auch, wie konsistent man irgendwelche Klitsches hinkriegt.
Wenn man sich überlegt, wie schwer man sich am Anfang getan hat, beispielsweise in Mario
64, diese ganzen, ähm, Backdingsbums, Longjumps da zu machen und wie konsistent das die Leute
heute teilweise hinkriegen, ist schon krass.
Also, das, da steckt verdammt viel Übung drin.
Gut, das ist jetzt Intro, Half-Life Intro.
Richtig anfangen tut es eigentlich ja erst hier.
Aber man sieht schon auch, es ist ja, es ist noch recht entspannt.
Hä, hängt das?
Ach ne, er bewegt sich nur einfach nicht.
Genau, hier irgendwo geht es los.
Und, ähm, es gibt wohl gleich am Anfang irgendeinen Klitsch, dass du diese Zwischensequenz nicht
überspringen kannst.
Es gibt, äh, es gibt ja am Anfang diese, es gibt ja am Anfang diese Zwischensequenz,
die eigentlich jetzt gleich kommt, wo, wo du von dem Blitz, von dem, von diesem Blitz,
von diesem Experiment getroffen wirst.
Und, dann kommt diese Xen-Zwischensequenz und das kann man irgendwie skippen, wenn man
es richtig macht.
Anscheinend, so irgendwie.
Wie auch immer, wie auch immer es funktioniert, ich habe keine Ahnung, aber das gibt die Zwischensequenz.
Und normalerweise ist man halt hier mit einem Drittel des Speeds irgendwie unterwegs.
Ach ja, und man kann irgendwie auch saven und loaden, wenn man in irgendwas reinspringen
würde, was jetzt eigentlich explodiert, dann, dann, dann loadet man und es passiert irgendwie
nichts.
Ähm, gibt es eigentlich News von Black Mesa, die meinten ja mal, dass die Xen-Levels fast
fertig sind.
Ja, ähm, die sind jetzt in der Beta, die, die, die Xen-Levels.
Endless Dimension, ja, stimmt, genau so, wie das, wie das ist.
Ich kenne mich damit auch nicht großartig aus.
Ich habe bloß halt ein paar Half-Life-Speedruns geguckt.
Ja.
Und dann habe ich mir ein paar Sachen gemerkt, die die Leute so erzählt haben.
Ähm, ah, es ist echt nice.
Das hier ist jetzt ja noch alles relativ, ähm, relativ geradlinig, ne.
Also an der Stelle, das ist der Weg, den man normalerweise auch als Casual-Spieler nimmt.
Nur halt ein bisschen schneller.
Aber, ähm, ich meine, okay, das ist vielleicht, also prinzipiell ist es der Weg, den man als
Casual-Spieler nimmt.
Allerdings jetzt vielleicht nicht so in dieser Art und Weise.
Vor allem schon mal gar nicht in der Geschwindigkeit, ne.
Ähm, das hier schon mal nicht.
Die haben jetzt ein komplettes Level übersprungen.
Normalerweise käme da jetzt, ähm, der, dieser, dieser Fahrstuhl-Kletter-Part.
Ja, weil es quasi, das ist irgendwie sich ein Level weitergeglitcht.
Dadurch, dass sie gespeichert haben vor dem Fahrstuhl, vor dem, vor dem, wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich ist in dem Fahrstuhl, das haben sie ja in Half-Life damals, ich rate jetzt
mal ein bisschen.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja von, von internen Details.
Ich weiß ja, Half-Life selbst nie gespeedrun oder so.
Ähm, was sie in Half-Life gerne gemacht haben, ist, dass du zwischen zwei Türen hattest du
quasi Level-Übergang-Trigger.
Also Level-Übergänge.
Und wahrscheinlich kannst du, wenn du quasi den Level-Übergang auslöst, allerdings
rausgehst, landest du wahrscheinlich in einem anderen.
Und die haben jetzt halt quasi die komplette Fahrstuhl- und Office-Sequenz übersprungen.
Normalerweise käme da ein ganzes Level dazwischen.
Oder kommt das jetzt mit dem Fahrstuhl und dem Office?
Ne, das ist jetzt Office-Sequenz.
Ja.
Das ist Office und Fahrstuhl, ne?
Oder?
Ich blick nicht mehr durch.
Es passiert zu viel.
Haha.
Es ist, es ist zu viel los.
Ich blicke nicht mehr durch.
Das, ist das jetzt Office?
Ne, das ist schon, das ist, ne, ne, das ist nach Office.
Das ist nicht mehr Office.
Der hat, der hat Office übersprungen.
Ich checke nicht, ich checke es nicht, das ist, das ist zu viel.
Zu viel auf einmal.
Ne, jetzt kommt der Fahrstuhl und Office.
Alter, was, was auch immer.
Keine Ahnung.
Gibt das was Fertiges?
Ja.
Moment.
Das ist definitiv nicht so gedacht normalerweise.
Normalerweise musst du hier einmal komplett im Kreis durch das Level laufen.
Kannst du dir rechnen, was kommt?
Das ist Plastpit, genau.
Das mit diesem Tentakel-Ding in der Mitte.
Also jetzt hat er auf jeden Fall ein komplettes Level übersprungen.
Plastpit ist das mit dem, mit dem Tentakel und der Rakete in der Mitte.
Kann sich wahrscheinlich jeder dran erinnern, der Half-Life gespielt hat.
Und man läuft gefühlt irgendwie, hier unten sieht man glaube ich die Geschwindigkeit von
ihm.
Normalerweise bist du halt viel, viel, viel, viel langsamer.
Und normalerweise fährst du hier auch mit so einem, mit so einem Auto lang.
Fährst mit so einem Auto lang und das bremst dann hier und dann fliegst du hier drüber.
Der denkt sich halt, YOLO, wozu?
Einfach durch die Suppe durch.
Was er jetzt macht, keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich, dass er mit möglichst viel Leben durch die Suppe kommt.
Endless Dimension runst du selbst Half-Life?
Oder ist das einfach auch nur...
Wissen aus Speedruns, die du geguckt hast.
Nur viel Speedruns geschaut.
Normalerweise geht man hier auch außen rum.
Es gibt am Ende noch einen Klitsch, wo du unendlich Leben kriegst.
Das kommt aber erst kurz, kurz vor, vor Lambda, vorm Lambda-Komplex.
Also kurz, kurz vor der, vor dem letzten Drittel.
Und das ist jetzt halt auch nice, was kommt.
Normalerweise bist du, normalerweise will das Game von dir, dass du quasi...
Ähm...
Bei jedem...
Bei jedem dieser Dinger hier einmal reingehst und irgendwas machst.
Und ähm...
Wobei, nee, du musst das machen, aber du kannst die Sachen halt auch überspringen, so.
Bäm.
Normalerweise musst du durch die Türen in der Mitte.
Und ich glaub, bei den Türen ist auch nochmal ne Ladezone und...
Ja.
Weil in der Mitte sind diese komischen Tentakel-Dinger, an die sich wahrscheinlich jeder Half-Life-Spieler erinnern kann.
Normalerweise hätte er da schon einmal durchgemusst.
Aber hat gedacht, wir überspringen das jetzt einfach mal.
Jetzt kommt der Generator, genau.
Das ist alles jetzt noch relativ...
Wie auch immer er das überlebt hat, hier das Runterspringen.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn du auf irgendeiner schrägen Fläche runterkommst oder sowas.
Äh, wieso kriegt er keinen Fallschaden?
Na, manchmal kriegt er Fallschaden, stirbt und reloadet.
Ich denk mal, es liegt daran...
Du musst, ähm...
Es ist ein bisschen wie...
Genau.
Max Electronics.
Es ist ein bisschen wie, wie CS...
CS Surfing.
Das ist, wenn du quasi auf nem...
Wenn du auf einer schrägen Fläche irgendwie runterkommst.
Und die schräge Fläche ist halt bei den Surf-Maps relativ groß.
Und hier war halt die schräge Fläche so nen...
Zentimetergroßer Schalter.
Aber es war ne...
War ne schräge Fläche.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es genau funktioniert, die Surfmechanik.
Aber es ist grundlegend das Gleiche.
Wie war denn der Speed da?
Ja.
Einfach mal...
Na, aber das spart halt Zeit.
Normalerweise müsstest du einmal komplett neue Zone laden in der Mitte.
Und durch dieses Zentakel-Ding durchgehen.
Wenn ich muss.
Das ist halt super weiches Movement, ja.
Das ist richtig geil zu sehen.
Da wird nirgendswo hängen geblieben.
Das geht...
Wenn gestoppt wird dann nur, wenn ne Tür im Weg ist, die halt einfach nicht schneller aufgeht.
Na, Prop-Jumping gibt's ja in Half-Life 1 nicht.
Oder?
Kannste ja keine Props nehmen und drauf rumjumpen.
Das Move-In, das ist übelst krass, ja.
Es sieht...
Es sieht mega easy aus, ne.
Es sieht einfach nur so aus, als würde er quasi...
Ähm...
Gerade auslaufen und die Maus ein bisschen drehen.
Wer mal versucht hat, in CS 1.6 ein bisschen zu Bunny-Hoppen...
Es ist ähnlich.
Es ist gar nicht einfach.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile würde ich das auch gar nicht mehr hinbekommen.
Du musst links und rechts draven und irgendwie die Maus richtig bewegen.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie es genau funktioniert.
Aber ich hab schon Probleme gehabt, geradeaus zu Bunny-Hoppen in CS.
Oh, jetzt muss er zu den Tentakeln.
Normalerweise hättest du bei diesen Tentakeln dreimal durchgemusst.
Oder zweimal durchgemusst.
Dreimal.
Jetzt muss er noch zurück.
Dreimal durchgemusst.
Holt er sich jetzt noch den Health-Boost ab?
Ja.
Jetzt gibt's noch einen Health-Boost.
Da gibt er mir jetzt eine Spritze, der Typ.
Genau.
Übrigens.
Der hat's nicht gesehen.
Der hat die Rakete ausgelöst oben, was die Tentakel wegbrennt.
Und man kann den Button drücken durch die Scheibe.
Normalerweise spielt man das ganz anders.
Also wenn man das Casual-mäßig spielt, musst du halt in den Raum rein, drückst auf den
Knopf, dann startet der Raketen-Booster und du kannst halt nicht aus dem Raum raus.
Der ist quasi an der Stelle, wo das Game überhaupt nicht will, dass er ist.
Also ich will nicht wissen, wie viele Stunden der Kalin Half-Life hat.
Das ist krass.
Huge.
Ja, ja.
Max Electronics geht mir genauso.
Ich hatte damals auch übelst Schiss.
Alter.
Fuck.
Epilepsie-Anfälle.
Ich musste Epilepsie-Warnung aussprechen vor dem Speedrun.
Zack.
Ach doch.
Du hast recht.
Ja, da hatte ich gerade geboostet mit den Kisten.
Normalerweise hätte er auch durch das komplette Level laufen müssen.
Ne?
Also.
Die.
Nice.
Ja, das ist On-Rail schon.
On-Rail nur ohne Rail.
Normalerweise fährt man hier mit so einem Auto auf Schienen,
mit so einem Mini-Kart auf Schienen lang.
Aber da denke ich einfach, wozu soll ich da auf Schienen lang fahren?
Ich kann einfach über die Schienen drüber springen.
Weil normalerweise kriegst du Elektro-Damage,
wenn du auf die Schienen trittst.
Also du kannst da gar nicht so drüber hüpfen.
Jetzt kommt das Raketending.
Ey, das Movement ist echt heftig.
Ich kann es nur erahnen, wie schwierig das ist.
Wie gesagt, ich habe es in CS nicht mehr geschafft,
zu Bunnyhoppen gescheit geradeaus.
Ich überlege mal, was sich so eine Wache denkt,
so nach dem Auto.
Oh, Freeman, Freeman!
Wo ist er hin?
Einfach mal so.
Zuck.
Hi, Jungs.
Zack.
Okay, anscheinend macht einem der Strom auch nichts,
wenn man das richtig timet.
Jetzt kommt diese Raketenstart-Sequenz.
Normalerweise muss man hier rein.
Da kann ich jetzt was zu erzählen,
weil das habe ich mir schon mal genau angeguckt.
Du kannst, also normalerweise musst du hier unten rein.
Links steht eine Rakete.
Normalerweise musst du hier rein,
einen Knopf drücken, dass die Rakete startet.
Er denkt sich aber, wozu?
Ich drücke den Knopf einfach von außen.
Allerdings muss er jetzt hinter die Tür,
weil ich vermute, vermute ich mal,
der muss hier rein, weil er sonst gekillt wird
von der Rakete draußen.
Würde ich, vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ich weiß nicht, warum er hier reingeht.
Eventuell auch einfach zum Hells, zum Hells schnappen,
bis halt diese Start-Sequenz vorbei ist.
Und normalerweise, wie gesagt, bist du gar nicht,
denkt das Game gar nicht, dass du draußen bist.
Du stehst normalerweise hier hinter dem,
da rechts oben, was man gesehen hat,
hier hinter dem, da.
Da oben stehst du hinter dem Fenster und guckst raus.
Die treffen ihn gar nicht, weil er zu schnell ist.
Jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt die Geschichte mit dem Fisch.
Da habe ich ja immer noch so ein bisschen Schiss davor,
weil als ich das das erste Mal gespielt habe,
hat mich, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das mit dem Fisch überhaupt sieht,
weil wo ich das das erste Mal gespielt habe,
habe ich nicht gecheckt, dass da ein Fisch in dem Wasser drin ist.
Und da fällst du in das Wasser rein,
auf einmal kommt so ein fetter Fisch und beißt dich.
Das war richtig MonkaS.
Vor dem Level habe ich heute noch ein bisschen Schiss.
Hat ja auch gerade einer geschrieben im Chat,
dass er vor dem Tentakel-Level noch Schiss hatte.
Ich habe, vor dem Level habe ich heute noch Schiss in Half-Life.
Vor dem Fisch im Wasser, ja.
Hier, das da.
Man sieht es gar nicht.
Da kommt so ein riesen Fisch raus, der dich auffrisst, so.
Normalerweise, wenn du in das Wasser fällst.
Also außer man überspringt das einfach alles.
Und ich habe es ja schon mal gesagt, ich habe eh Schiss vor tiefem Wasser.
Ich habe keine Höhenangst oder sonst was.
Ich habe aber irgendwie Schiss vor tiefem Wasser.
Und ich weiß auch nicht, warum.
Das ist für mich übelst MonkaS, das Level.
Tiefenangst, genau. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das Wort gibt.
Ach ja, aber übrigens nur, wenn ich es nicht sehe, ne.
Wenn ich, ähm,
so im Schwimmbad,
irgendwie,
ich habe übel Schiss, beispielsweise früher,
hatte ich übel Schiss, in das, das, das Springbecken reinzugehen.
Ich hatte keinen Schiss, vorm, vorm Brett zu springen.
Ähm, sondern Schiss vor,
vor dem Wasser,
unter dem Sprungbecken.
Also, nein, vor dem Wasser im Springbecken, nicht vor dem Sprungbrett hatte ich früher Schiss.
Also, ich bin,
ich, ich hatte überhaupt keine Probleme,
vor dem, von dem zehn, keine Ahnung, von zehn Meter runter zu springen, aber ich hatte Schiss,
lange in diesem Wasser zu schwimmen, wo man reinspringt.
Komisch, oder?
Weiß auch nicht, warum.
Und, hab ich, so, hab ich so, bauchgefühlmäßig hab ich das immer noch.
Allerdings, wo ich dann irgendwie lustigerweise keinen Schiss mehr hab, ist,
sobald ich eine Taucherbrille aufhab,
und in dem gleichen Wasser untergetaucht bin.
Da hab ich dann keinen Schiss mehr.
Dann sehe ich alles, und dann kann, oh, easy, ist doch überhaupt kein Ding.
Aber sobald ich von, von außen in das Wasser reingucke, hab ich übel Schiss davor.
Wahrscheinlich, weil das Licht sich irgendwie unterschiedlich bricht, und es viel tiefer aussieht, oder so, keine Ahnung.
Gibt's so Sachen, kann man auch nicht unbedingt erklären, gut.
Oder sich nicht rational erklären, irgendwie.
So, jetzt kommt der Kühlraum,
wo man eigentlich Damage kriegt,
wenn man zu lang drinne ist.
Allerdings, äh, ist er so schnell, dass er da durch ist.
Jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt die, äh, Assassin-Geschichte.
Also normalerweise, im nächsten Raum, ich, wir werden's im Speedrun wahrscheinlich gar nicht sehen,
normalerweise im nächsten Raum wird man von so, von, glaub, vier oder fünf, äh,
so, Assassin-Grills angegriffen.
Mit Silencer-Pistole.
Allerdings, anscheinend, das wusste ich auch nicht,
muss man die Assassin-Typen gar nicht, oder die, die Assassin-Grills gar nicht bekämpfen,
sondern kann gleich in den Cutscene-Raum rein.
So, jetzt kommt die Zwischensequenz, an die sich wahrscheinlich auch jeder erinnern kann,
der Half-Life mal gespielt hat, wo man seine ganze Ausrüstung abgenommen kriegt.
Also, ne, Story-technisch wird man jetzt quasi niedergeschlagen worden, gefangen genommen worden
und kriegt seine ganze Ausrüstung abgenommen.
Und die Wachen unterhalten sich jetzt gerade drüber, dass sie ja einfach, ähm,
die, sie liefern Freeman nicht ab, sondern, sondern werfen ihn einfach quasi in die,
in die Schrottpresse, dass man den Körper nicht findet.
So.
Jetzt ist er halt in der Schrottpresse drin.
Und jetzt ist er auch aus der Schrottpresse schon wieder gekommen.
Wie, äh, was ich damals für nen...
Ich hab's damals überhaupt nicht gecheckt, wie man aus der Schrottpresse rauskommt.
Und er springt einfach zwei Mal und ist raus. Easy.
Ja, Max Electronics, das stimmt.
Für, für das, wie man, man muss das sagen, grafisch, ne,
grafisch sieht's halt nicht sonderlich immersive aus, die ganzen Half-Life-Geschichten.
Aber was, was Half-Life ausgemacht hat, war letztendlich,
dass du gerade keine Zwischensequenzen im, im, im traditionellen Sinn hattest, ja,
und auch keine Zwischensequenz-Videos, sondern es war alles Ego-Perspektive, immer ingame Grafik.
Du hast, glaub ich, im kompletten Half-Life,
nicht eine Szene, die nicht ingame Grafik ist.
Ja, und Leute, es sagt jetzt keiner das Hauptmenü, ja.
Also, ich mein, wenn man das Spiel gestartet hat.
So, das Level mag keiner.
Das ist jetzt hier Hindernis-Parcours.
Man kann das bewegen?
Ich wusste überhaupt nicht, dass man das bewegen kann, das Zeug.
Hab ich noch nie gesehen. Wusste gar nicht, dass man das bewegen kann.
Jetzt bricht das Rohr gleich ein.
Macht nix, springt drüber.
Das Movemen ist echt übelst...
Ja.
Und hier hat sich wahrscheinlich auch jeder erstmal verlaufen, der Half-Life gespielt hat.
Zum ersten Mal gespielt hat.
Und hatte Schiss, dass er permanent von irgendwelchen Dingern zerquetscht, zerdrückt, zersonstfasst wird.
Wie er sich überhaupt nicht für den Gegner interessiert.
So, jetzt kommt ein bisschen Parkour-Action.
Da war ja, äh, Half-Life berühmt, berüchtigt für.
Was vielen Leuten nicht gefallen hat, ich persönlich fand das eigentlich nice.
Jetzt hat er wieder keinen Fallschaden gekriegt, weil er auf nem, auf nem schrägen Untergrund gelandet ist.
Also, quasi, gesurft.
Dass man da einfach drüber springen kann, okay.
Ich glaub, jeder von uns hat versucht, ähm, den Strom auszuschalten vorher.
Der Witz ist ja, der, der ist jetzt nach, der ist, der ist über die Hälfte vom Game schon fertig jetzt.
An den Part kann ich mich jetzt gar nicht mehr erinnern, wo das ist.
Ach, das ist das, wo man die, wo man die Forscher retten muss, aus diesem komischen, vor diesem komischen, äh, Hackfleisch-Ding da.
Weil, den Typ braucht man, dass er die Tür aufmacht.
Aber normalerweise muss man da doch andersrum durch, ne?
Jetzt holt er sich erstmal seine Waffe? Ne, macht er nicht.
Ich dachte, ich dachte, da hinten gibt's diese, diese, diese...
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie dieses, wie diese Waffe in Half-Life heißt, diese...
Das Ding, was sich dreht und, und so Laserstrahlen verschießt.
Ja, das Ding da. Wie heißt denn das in Half-Life überhaupt, diese Waffe?
Damit kannst du dich, äh, boosten.
Wie lange man würde für, wie lange würde man für das Game als Casual brauchen?
Half-Life ist ziemlich lang für nen Ego-Shooter. Ich würd mal sagen, so sieben Stunden?
Sieben, acht Stunden?
Oder noch länger?
Ich glaube, man hat für Half-Life 1 noch länger gebraucht.
Das, wenn ich mir das angucke, was Endless Dimension da gepostet hat,
es ist eher wahrscheinlich, dass man zwölf, vierzehn Stunden braucht, oder vielleicht sogar länger.
Half-Life 1 war, Half-Life 1 ist eines der längsten, äh, so Ego-Shooter-Games, die mir einfallen.
Das, das, das hat sehr viele Levels, und wenn man denkt, es ist fertig, geht's noch weiter.
Das hatte ich so in noch keinem anderen Game.
Die meisten anderen Games, die ich, die ich so spiele, denkste so, ey, jetzt passiert mal was geil, und dann ist es fertig.
Und in Half-Life war es so.
Du hast gedacht, oh, geschafft, es ist fertig, und dann ging's weiter.
Du hast bei Half-Life, hast du zwei Stellen, wo du denkst, es ist theoretisch fertig, ja.
Einmal, wo du gefangen genommen wirst und alle Waffen verlierst.
Das hat damals, glaub ich, noch kein Game vorher gemacht, das ist keins, was mir einfällt.
Denkst du, oh, scheiße, ist vorbei.
So quasi wird fortgesetzt.
Das nächste ist, wenn du, ähm, den Part auf der Erde beendet hast, denkst du, ah, okay, jetzt ist fertig.
Und, ähm, das dritte Mal ist, wenn's wirklich fertig ist.
Half-Life ist ziemlich lang.
Wenn, der überspringt ja auch die meisten Sachen.
Die meisten Räume ist da überhaupt nicht drin, die es gibt.
Normalerweise musst du hier einmal komplett im Kreis laufen und, und die Wissenschaftler holen und den Laser einschalten und alles, und erst dann darfst du raus.
Wobei ich eher empfehlen würde, Black Mesa zu spielen, anstatt das originale Half-Life 1.
The fuck?
Normalerweise musst du oben rüber über den, über den, ähm, Damm und noch den Heli killen und sowas.
Und wenn Black Mesa mal die Xen-Levels fertig hat, ist das wirklich das bessere Half-Life 1.
Und hier muss man normalerweise auch außen rumlaufen.
Ich find's auch cool, wie, wie gut die Route getimt ist, mit, ähm, wo er Healthpacks aufsammeln kann und wo er sich Damage boostet und sowas.
Normalerweise ist der Boden vermint und man kann da gar nicht langlaufen.
Außer man kennt halt den genauen Weg.
Willste Black Mesa dann on stream zocken? Kann, ist ne gute Idee, aber erst wenn die Xen-Level...
Oh, KS!
The fuck? Moment, das muss ich mir nochmal angucken. Das war ja nice.
Das war ja echt nice.
Guck mal.
Normalerweise musst du hier unten langlaufen, unten langlaufen, da langlaufen, nochmal den Heli bekämpfen, langlaufen, hochklettern und zurück zur, äh, zurück zum Tunnel.
Und der macht einfach...
The fuck?
Das ist Huge Pog, äh...
Ich will nicht wissen, wie lange er dafür geübt hat.
Splatter, splatter.
Äh...
Was war das jetzt?
Achso, der hat den Fight resettet.
Okay, wir springen einfach über die Levels drüber.
Ja, okay, alles klar. Jetzt kommt dieses explosive Haus da.
Da, wo du normalerweise, normalerweise musst du hier...
Also, das ist gar nicht, das ist ziemlich schwierig, dieses Level, wenn man das zum ersten Mal spielt.
Das hier ist ein Lagerhaus, komplett mit, mit diesen, mit diesen, äh, Laserminen voll.
Und normalerweise ist es in Half-Life ja so, du kannst von Weitem diese, diese Laserminen kannst du auslösen, da passiert dir nix.
Allerdings hier ist das Game halt zu Ende, wenn du sie Luft sprengst, weil es fliegt das ganze Lagerhaus in die Luft.
Und all...
Jeder, der das das erste Mal spielt, braucht eine halbe Stunde, bis er durch ist.
Tja, YOLO.
Einfach wieder das halbe Level übersprungen.
Jetzt musst du die Tür aufschießen.
Normalerweise musst du...
Aber das Lagerhaus war noch nicht mal drin, was, was in der Zwischenzeit kommt.
Echt pock. Echt nice, also...
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung mehr.
Jetzt kommt der unendliche Leben-Klitsch.
Den sieht man eigentlich in jedem Half-Life-Speedrun.
Das, es funktioniert irgendwie so, man sieht hier unten auch seine Hells, seine Hells, ähm, overflowt.
Das funktioniert folgendermaßen, aber ich hatte mir mal, hat mal irgendjemand erklärt in einem Speedrun.
Wenn du eingeklemmt bist, man sieht ja hier den Damage-Indikator.
Wenn du eingeklemmt bist und nuckelst an einem Hells-Pack.
Oder, vielleicht reicht es auch, wenn du eingeklemmt bist?
Ich weiß nicht, dann overflowt deine Hells und da hat jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 8000 Hells oder so.
Und normalerweise soll man hier das Ding in die Luft sprengen.
Man hat, man hat da hinten so einen, so einen, so einen Turm mit, ähm, mit, mit so einem Artillerie-Geschütz drauf.
Den musst du normalerweise da draufschießen lassen, dass das aufgeht.
Er ist confused.
Ich bin permanent confused, wenn ich das sehe.
So, jetzt kommen die ganzen Levels, wo sich Militär und, und Aliens normalerweise bekriegen.
Davon kriegt er aber halt nicht viel mit.
Weil, durchrennen.
Weil Speedrun.
Jetzt kann er übrigens Damage boosten, so viel er will.
Weil er hat, nicht unendlich Leben, aber er hat massig viel Leben.
Das kriegt, also, das reicht.
Er muss sich jetzt überhaupt keine Gedanken mehr über irgendwie Leben machen.
Wie gesagt, er hat jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 800.000 Leben oder so, massig viel Leben.
Also, reicht, reicht bis zum Ende des Runs aus.
Jetzt kommen nochmal ein paar Assassin-Grills.
Allerdings werden die einfach auch geskippt.
Half-Life-Speedruns sind eines der geilsten Speedruns, finde ich.
Erstmal voll mit dem Ding in die Eier geballert.
Ernst Overflow IRL.
Ja, das wär mal was.
Aber, also für dieses Movement hat er hunderte Stunden geübt.
Da hat er hunderte Stunden für geübt.
Ich meine, allein schon das Movement, was man eben gesehen hat, mit diesem Rückwärts-Rückwärts-Jump,
das hat wahrscheinlich alles irgendwelche Namen, ja.
Durch die Öffnung, durch die Tür in den Fahrstuhlschacht.
Und normalerweise musst du hier auch, bevor du da durch kannst,
also, das muss wohl auch irgendein Klitsch sein, dass das überhaupt auf ist.
Normalerweise musst du einmal komplett außen rum laufen, den Reaktor einschalten,
das Kühlsystem einschalten, das Kühlsystem überlasten, bla, ja.
Also, da brauchst du dann normalerweise schon allein eine Stunde, um diese Sektion zu spielen.
Normalerweise.
Jetzt kommt eine der nervigsten Sachen in ganz Half-Life.
Die halt einfach mal überspringt mit einer Granate.
Diese Teleport-Einlage im, im...
Im Teleporter-Ding da.
Wie auch immer das heißt.
Da musst du normalerweise von einem Teleporter zum anderen springen.
Jetzt ist kurz ein bisschen Downtime, jetzt muss er warten, bis die Tür...
Moment, warum ist die Tür schon auf?
Normalerweise...
Moment.
Moment, Moment, Leute.
Das war mir jetzt zu viel.
Normalerweise musst du dir erstmal eine halbe Stunde den Vortrag anhören.
Normalerweise musst du dir eine halbe Stunde den Vortrag von den Wissenschaftlern und den Wachen anhören,
was Sache ist, bevor die die Tür überhaupt aufmachen.
Und dann musst du normalerweise, wenn du hier in diesen Raum reingehst,
musst du, da oben steht ein Wissenschaftler drin, den musst du beschützen für glaube ich 3, 4 Minuten,
vor hier spawnenden Aliens und erst dann geht der Teleporter auf.
Aber anscheinend kann man in den Teleporter einfach reinspringen und gut ist.
Easy.
So jetzt, jetzt wird's übelst abgedreht auf Xen.
Also da wird kein Level so gemacht wie intended.
Teilweise, wobei teilweise schon.
Das nächste Level wird glaube ich halbwegs gemacht wie intended.
Nämlich gegen dieses komische, diese Alien-Krabbe.
Okay.
Dialog-Skript, äh...
Wie gesagt, ich hab ja Half-Life selbst nie gerunt, ich kenn das ja auch nur vom Runs gucken.
Runt einer von euch Half-Life? Nur mal so gefragt, so.
Könnte ja sein.
Bei 155 Zuschauern.
Ähm, ich glaub das hier wird halbwegs intended gemacht,
weil du sonst nicht weiter kannst.
Wenn das Ding nicht die Netze kaputt macht.
Was ist die Unterschiede zwischen meinem Schub und Lambda Core und dem Timer?
So, jetzt kriegt's erstmal den Euter in die Luft gesprengt.
Bam.
Milch ist Gift, sag ich da nur zu.
Genau, und das musst du jetzt halbwegs wie intended machen, dass diese Netze, dass das Viech diese Netze kaputt macht.
Sonst kannst du nicht weiter.
Da sieht man auch mal, dass man da, wie man jung war und das zum ersten Mal gespielt hat,
unsinnig Schiss vor diesem Viech gehabt hat.
Das ist nämlich komplett durchgeskriptet und macht dir zum größten Teil noch nicht mal was.
Damals hast du halt dem Ding viel mehr KI zugetraut, als es eigentlich hatte.
Und du kriegst auch nicht mal Damage, wenn du hier dran stehst.
Du hattest also das erste Mal gespielt, hast übel Schiss.
Ach ja, und normalerweise ist das jetzt so gedacht,
dieses Krabbenviech fällt hier runter und explodiert quasi, geht kaputt und der Boden geht kaputt.
Allerdings kann man den Boden auch mit genug Sprengstoff aufsprengen, was er jetzt hier macht.
Er brauchst halt schon ein bisschen Sprengstoff, dass es funktioniert.
So, und jetzt kann er den Teleporter, lange bevor dieses Alienviech überhaupt da ist,
der hat übrigens gerade wieder mehr oder weniger das ganze Level geskippt.
Das ist übelst heftig, das Movement, der Wahnsinn.
Jetzt kommt diese Alienfabrik, das ist das Level, was ich am wenigsten gemacht habe in ganz Half-Life hier.
Das da.
Oh, er wird nervös, weil er merkt, dass er nah am Weltrekord ist.
Muss er da unten drunter durchkrabbeln? Ja.
Okay, das ist die normale Route, die man so auch nimmt als Casual.
Halt nicht ganz so schnell.
Und das macht man als Casual nicht.
Normalerweise musst du da ewig lange hochklettern, bis du da bist.
Das dauert eine Stunde oder so, bis du da oben bist, wenn du das zum ersten Mal spielst.
Jetzt kommt Endboss.
Ach nee, jetzt muss er erst noch durch dieses Ding hier drüber, aber jetzt kommt Endboss.
Meinst du, in diesen Speedruns wird viel gecheatet? Nö, da wird überhaupt nicht gecheatet.
Keiner, der bei Sinn ist, cheatet in einem Speedrun.
Erstens, weil das Beschiss quasi an der ganzen Community ist.
Und außerdem, weil du ja, wenn du da irgendwelche Sachen verwirrst, kannst du deinen Speedrun gar nicht einreichen.
Es wird bestimmt versucht zu bescheißen. Es gab hier letztens diese News drüber, dass irgendjemand quasi segmentet hat,
was war das, ein Super Meat Boy Speedrun, glaube ich, segmentet hat, obwohl es eigentlich am Stück sein sollte.
Aber zum größten Teil, würde ich sagen, ist diese ganze Speedrun-Geschichte eines der Szenen,
wo es am meisten Skill gibt und am wenigsten Beschiss.
Ja, und außerdem musst du das eh livestreamen und, genau.
Oder zumindest halt im Zusammenhang mit dem Video zeigen können.
Der Boss ist relativ easy, auch wenn man Casual spielt, finde ich.
Das Ding hat ganz wirre Hitboxen, also man denkt, man kann dem nur...
Also, als Casual denkt man, man muss dem in den Kopf schießen, muss man aber gar nicht.
Das Game tut nur so.
Oh, jetzt dreht er, jetzt dreht er durch.
Jetzt dreht er ab.
Easy Win, Easy Life.
Krasser Run. Echt krasser Run.
Meine Maus.
Huge Run. Echt nice.
Also, der kann's.
Wie viel war da schneller? Können wir mal gucken.
Der war schneller...
Die Speedrun-Seite lädt grad nicht.
Ähm...
Der war schneller...
20 Sekunden!
Das ist übelst viel.
20 Sekunden, das ist... das ist echt krass, ja.
Also, ich vermute zumindest mal, dass das ziemlich viel sind in diesem High-Level-Segment, ja.
Was bedeutet Scripted?
Das ist, wenn man keinen Bock hat, die ganzen Glitches und Tricks zu lernen,
dann kann man das...
dann kann man quasi Scripts zur Hilfe verwenden.
Scripted ist quasi eher was für die, äh...
Ich denke mal für Leute, die... die... die nicht da ihre 1000 Stunden reinstecken wollen.
Und du hast beispielsweise genau, so wie du es Endless Dimension sagst,
das Movement ist halbwegs automatisiert, dass du nicht manuell bunnyhoppen musst.
Allerdings, der Witz ist, dass...
Scripted...
langsamer ist...
als Scriptless.
Komisch, oder?
Scripted sollte eigentlich einfacher sein.
Aber das scheint wohl daran zu liegen, dass die absoluten Top Half-Life-Runner
eben Scriptless runnen und nicht Scripted.
Also, wenn jetzt hier einer der Top 3 auf die Idee kommen würde, mal... mal irgendwie Scripted zu üben,
dann wäre er wahrscheinlich eine ganze Ecke schneller als... äh...
als die Scripted-Typen.
Scripted mit SW?
Habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Gibt es Einschränkungen, was ein Script macht?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wie gesagt, ich runne selbst kein Half-Life und ähm...
Ich kenne das auch nur aus Streams, ich weiß es nicht.
Allerdings, man kann sich hier...
Die haben ja einen Forum, die haben einen Discord und so und die haben ja auch einen...
Irgendwo kannst du dir auch die Regeln angucken.
Playstation 2 Half-Life Speedrun.
Fragen gibt's.
Ich finde es schon echt cool, also...
Das Movement ist echt nicht... nicht von dieser Welt, was... was der Kerl da gezeigt hat gerade.
Was? View Rules? Wo?
Ach, da!
Ne, das sind die Rules, weil man was submitten darf, denke ich.
Ja doch, genau.
Ah, hier steht auch, was für Skripte nicht erlaubt sind.
Ähm, dass man... dass man schneller schießt, man Damage macht ist nicht erlaubt, ähm...
Third-Party-Makros sind nicht erlaubt, also wenn ich jetzt mit meiner Makro-Software von der... von der Tastatur mache...
Ähm...
Oder irgendwelche anderen Dinger.
Auto-Champ, Duck-Tap...
Auto-Champ-Bug, was auch immer.
Ich weiß nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich run das selbst nicht.
Hab ich auch nicht vor.
Ich guck's mir nur gerne an.
Es ist eh erstaunlich, wie sehr diese Speedrun-Geschichte die letzten Jahre gewachsen ist, ne?
Ähm...
Ich guck ja schon ewig die größeren Events.
Also ich hab auch ESA... ESA 2013 oder so schon geguckt.
Und es... oder 2012 war das erste, ich weiß nicht.
Ich guck das... ich guck das quasi schon seit Anfang an.
Und wie groß diese Events mittlerweile sind.
Am Anfang war das... saßen da drei Dudes in nem Zimmer.
Teilweise noch nicht mal irgendwie in nem... das war dann irgendwie im... in... in...
Im Schlafzimmer von irgendeinem Typ damals, sozusagen.
Und heute hast du quasi ne Halle drinne, ne Halle mit... mit 300 Leuten oder so.
Das ist echt heftig.
Äh, wie hieß noch mal das RPG in der Source-Engine, das du schon mal im Stream gespielt hast?
Das war... Dark Messiah of Might and Magic war das.
Sehr einzigartiges Game.
Gibt's eigentlich nichts Vergleichbares in dieser Form.
Viele sagen, wenn sie diese Bilder sehen erstmal, es sieht ein bisschen aus wie Elder Scrolls.
Allerdings wird er feststellen, dass das...
Wenn wir das spielen, dass das Combat-System überhaupt nichts mit Elder Scrolls zu tun hat.
Außer, dass es Ego-Perspektive ist.
Gibt es auch komplett Tool-Assisted Runs, klar.
Klar.
Kann man da Bunny-Hotten?
Vielleicht, ich mein, das ist ein Source-Game.
Würd mich nicht wundern, wenn du da irgendwie sowas machen könntest.
So, ähm...
Wie ist eigentlich...
Wie ist das eigentlich geworden?
Das hatte ich... das hatte ich so auf dem Schirm, dass das demnächst rauskommt.
Das ist aber nicht so gut.
Weil ich dachte mir, wenn das mal wieder... wenn das ein gutes Koop-Game ist, da wär das was, wo ich vielleicht den Friseur dazu überreden könnte.
Die GoldenEye-Speedruns sind auch geil. Ja, das stimmt.
Die GoldenEye-Speedruns sind auch nice.
Also es gibt saumäßig viele... saumäßig viele Speedruns, die geil anzuschauen sind.
Weil die Klassiker schlechthin sind natürlich Mario 64, Ocarina of Time, Mario 1 und Mario World und so weiter.
Ich glaub vor allem Mario 64 und Ocarina of Time dürften so die meist geruntesten, äh, schon so die mainstreamigsten Speedruns eigentlich sein.
Also auf jeden Fall mit die bekanntesten.
Das hat aber keine gute Bewertung, das neue Wolfenstein.
Ausgeglichen. Warum?
Fuck, was? Give me fucking powers in singleplayer.
GTA ist auch recht beliebt, ja, allerdings...
Ich würd sagen, äh, Ocarina of Time und Mario 64 sind so die bekanntesten.
Ja gut, es gibt ja kein Singleplayer, oder? Ich dachte, das Game ist komplett Koop.
Insanely repetitive and boring.
Ähm, das hab ich auch schon gesehen.
Dass die jetzt in diesem Wolf... die haben jetzt im... in... in... hier in Youngblood haben die so ein Level-System drinne.
Dass die... dass die Gegner, obwohl es immer die gleichen Gegner sind, quasi mitleveln.
Man darf auch nicht vergessen, das ist ein Spiel...
Das ist in Zusammenarbeit entstanden von den Dishonored Dudes und... noch irgendjemand.
Und das merkt man.
Das hat mir schon beim ersten Mal, wo ich das gesehen hab, dass es Levels gibt, nicht gefallen.
Und anscheinend ist das auch keine... anscheinend ist es auch nicht so gut geworden.
Also ich muss sagen, die... was... was hat die GameStar gegeben?
Warum Youngblood das schwächste neue Wolfenstein ist.
Fetzigen Koop.
Das ist so eine typische GameStar... so eine typische GameStar-Redewendung.
Addiert fetzigen Koop.
In ähm... in Diablo haben sie... da hat die GameStar früher geschrieben...
Nicht Hack and Slay, sondern hat immer geschrieben...
Äh, Blizzards wilde Monsterhatz.
Das ist so typisch GameStar.
Blizzards wilde Monsterhatz.
Da hab ich damals schon immer gecringed, wo ich das in der GameStar gelesen hab.
Obwohl ich damals nicht mehr wusste, dass man das cringe... cringe nennt, ne?
Boomer, genau.
Wobei, wenn hier einer der Boomer ist, dann ich, ne? Mit 35.
Wo ist denn die Bewegung?
Äh, nicht Bewegung, die Bewertung.
Guck mal, Fazit, Wertung.
Wertung.
Ach, haben die mittlerweile gar keine Prozent mehr?
Hat die ge... ah doch, da oben. 75.
Gecringed, ja.
Äh, 75.
Für den schnellen Action-Hubs am Abend.
Das ist auch wieder so ein typischer GameStar... so ein typischer GameStar-Satz.
Für den schnellen Action-Hubs am Abend ist Youngblood... äh, Youngblood prima.
Wer seinen Wolfenstein lieber gehaltvoll mag, bleibt bei der Hauptserie.
Der schnelle Action-Hubs am Abend.
Das ist so typisch... typisch GameStar irgendwie.
Easy.
Kann man das mittlerweile uns jetzt hier in Deutschland spielen? Kein Schimmer.
Ich glaub... ich glaub New Colossus war doch gar nicht in Deutschland großartig zensiert.
Außer, außer halt Nazi-Symbole.
Dünne Handlung, blödes kurz vor Ende.
Okay.
Warum Youngblood das schwächste neue Wolfenstein ist.
Okay, was sagt er?
Wie schon ganz zu Beginn der Story-Seite nicht viel...
Ja gut, ähm, das hätte ich jetzt auch nicht erwartet.
Wobei ich sagen muss, das letzte Wolfenstein fand ich die Story gar nicht so dumm.
Die hatten... die hatten... also im letzten Wolfenstein waren viele WTF-Momente drin.
Da zum Beispiel, wo du geköpft wirst und denkst, oh fuck, was jetzt?
Und dann... dann... wo sie dann deinen Kopf bergen irgendwie und dich auf so'n... so'n... dich wieder festschrauben.
Ich fand die New Colossus-Story gar nicht schlecht.
Aber dass das kurz vor Ende derart schwachfugig ausfällt, damit hätte ich dann doch nicht gerechnet.
Aha.
Ich will Blazkowicz oder den verantwortlichen Autor immer noch ein bisschen schütteln, wenn ich an diesen Blödsinn denke.
Okay, na gut, wir wissen es ja nicht.
Aber... na gut.
Also sie finden's... die Gamestar finden's nicht toll.
Ich muss ja sagen, ich bin... ich hatte ja früher mal sogar ein Gamestar-Abo, ne?
Ähm, ich hab schon ewig kein Gamestar-Abo mehr.
Allerdings, trotzdem muss ich sagen, auch wenn viel auf die Gamestar geschimpft wird
und auch wenn ihre Seite an sich...
mittlerweile jetzt nicht unbedingt jetzt mehr so...
wie soll ich das jetzt sagen, so den... den...
gehaltvollste...
Gaming-Journalismus widerspiegelt, ja.
Aber zum größten Teil finde ich die Gamestar immer noch das Beste, was wir in Deutschland haben.
So von den althergebrachten Zeitungen.
Ähm...
Na, manche Sachen sind halt easy... easy... easy-click-crap, den sie machen.
Aber das kann man ihnen auch nicht wirklich vorwerfen, weil ich meine, die müssen Geld verdienen.
Die müssen sehen... die müssen sehen, wo sie bleiben.
Ähm...
Zum größten Teil ist die Gamestar immer noch das Beste, was wir haben.
Wow, top gillend verzweifeln am schlechtesten Boss aller Zeiten.
Das ist auch wieder so ein... so ein... so ein... so ein... so ein...
Click-Crap.
So wie ich das mitgekriegt hab, wurde der jetzt eigentlich gelegt mittlerweile?
Wurde der eigentlich gelegt jetzt, der neue... der... der neue... äh...
Boss?
Ne, anscheinend nicht.
Wenn der gelegt worden wäre, würde jetzt hier stehen, ähm...
First... World First.
Wurde der jetzt gekleert mittlerweile?
Anscheinend nicht.
Ähm...
Beim aktuellen WoW-Boss ist es ja wohl auch so, dass sich...
Deswegen, was die Gamestar da schreibt, ist so ein bisschen, ähm...
Naja...
Die Spieler regen sich nicht darüber auf, dass es zu schwer wäre, der Boss.
Sondern die Spieler regen sich darüber auf, dass der Boss wohl scheiß Mechaniken hat.
Zum Beispiel gibt es wohl irgendwelche Line-Offs, die sagen...
Line-Off-Side-Checks.
Und zwar nicht nur Line-Off-Side-Checks zum Spielercharakter.
Sondern Line-Off-Side-Checks zu irgendwelchen Apps, die man tanken muss.
Und die halt... sich nicht so bewegen, wie man das gerne hätte.
Oh, Flo69's Big Brain, ja.
Azshara ist noch unlegbar.
Okay, er wusste ja nicht, ob das immer noch so ist, aber...
Das letzte Mal, wo ich geguckt habe, am Freitag, hatte sie irgendeine Gilde auf 49%.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie es jetzt aussieht.
Gronkh spielt das. Mit wem spielt Gronkh das, dein Koop?
Ah, mit dem da anscheinend. Wer ist das? Kennt man den?
Ich kenne auf YouTube eh keinen mehr.
Ja, habe ich noch nie gehört.
Aber das heißt doch nichts, weil ich kenne mich auf YouTube nicht mehr aus, was das angeht.
Sag mal!
Leute, ihr seid ja doch bestimmt informierter als ich.
Was war denn eigentlich da letztens los?
Ich habe nur irgendwie auf Twitter gelesen, dass sich alle darüber aufgeregt haben...
...dass Gronkh irgendein Let's-Play-Format mit irgendeinem Currywurst nicht mehr macht, weil irgendwelche Sachen waren.
Was ist da los, Leute? Jetzt müsst ihr mir mal erklären, was ist da los?
Das willst du, glaube ich, gar nicht wissen. Doch, ich will es jetzt wissen, ja.
Lass mich raten. Irgendeiner ist fremdgegangen mit einem aus der Let's-Play-Gruppe.
Weil meistens sind ja die Sachen so ganz...
...immer so zwischenmenschlich, ja?
Es ist bestimmt irgendeiner fremdgegangen oder so.
Was? Er hat mit Minderjährigen geschrieben und damit seine Freundin dreimal...
Das ist doch sein Ding, äh...
Also, ob der fremdgeht, ist ja nur wirklich mal sein Ding.
Aber gut, ich habe die ganze Sache nicht mitgekriegt.
Aha.
Okay, YouTube-Drama. Ich sehe es schon. Ich sehe es schon.
Deutschland-YouTube-Drama mal wieder.
Und wahrscheinlich wollen die ganzen Fanboys jetzt natürlich auch alles ganz detailliert wissen und sind böse, dass ihnen keiner...
...dass man nicht jedes Detail des Privatlebens offenlegen will. Könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Zumindest ist das immer so, wenn du auf Twitter das liest, ja, dann hast du dann immer die übelsten Fanboys am Start.
So nach dem Motto, ja bla bla bla, dem glaube ich kein Wort.
Der war schon immer so hinterlistig und warum erzählt er uns denn auch nicht, was er immer so genau macht und so.
Wo ich mir immer denke, ey, als ist irgendjemand verpflichtet, seinen Fanboys auf Twitter genau offen zu legen, wann er aufs Klo geht.
YouTube-Drama. YouTube-Drama.
Ich folge auch keinem, deswegen weiß ich es nicht.
Ich habe das nur in den Twitter-Trends gesehen.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, ich muss jetzt mal fragen, was da eigentlich los ist, ja.
YouTube-Drama ist immer das beste Drama. YouTube-Drama-Beste.
Wisst ihr, früher war es ein Drama, wenn der eine dem anderen die Pentanuke weggeklaut hat.
Und mittlerweile ist es ja auch nicht besser, als in irgendeiner Soap im Fernsehen.
Äh, Xtronny ist bei mir genauso, Fernsehen gucke ich nicht und Mainstreet Deutschland wohlgemerkt, Mainstreet YouTube gucke ich auch nicht.
Ich hasse Deutschland-YouTube, äh, Deutschland-YouTube ist so ein, so ein Dreck.
Nicht alle, man muss, man kann nicht, man kann es nicht so pauschal auf alle sagen, aber zum größten Teil ist YouTube-Deutschland totaler Dreck.
YouTube-Deutschland will aber auch, dass es Dreck ist.
Viele, es gab ja ein paar Channels, die haben auf Deutsch Videos gemacht, wollte keine Sau sehen, machen sie auf Englisch Videos, finden es alle geil.
Zum Beispiel, wenn es ein bisschen in Richtung, in Richtung Science und so geht.
Diese, die ganz, die, diese, diese, diese, wie heißt das?
Kurz gesagt, die haben früher Videos auf Deutsch gemacht, wollte kein Mensch sehen, machen sie Videos auf Englisch, BÄM, schlägt voll ein.
YouTube-Deutschland ist komplett für den Arsch.
YouTube-Deutschland ist das schlimmste, so diese, die, die schlimmste nur anzunehmende Mischung aus, aus Casual-sensationsgeilen Deppen.
Let's, Let's Play guckenden, sensationsgeilen Casual-Spielern.
Und Beauty-Grills.
Das ist YouTube-Deutschland.
Fake Pranks.
Oder keine Fake Pranks, wofür man dann erstmal in den Knast muss.
Kann sich noch jemand an den, an den Apo, Apo-Red-Bomben-Prank erinnern?
Das ist so hängen geblieben, Alter, so hängen geblieben.
Digga.
Oh Mann.
Das ist YouTube-Deutschland, das ist so, das ist so dämlich.
Habt ihr eure Jeezy's schon an alle, ja?
Mit dem Prank?
Der hat doch irgendwann mal nen, nen...
Ja, was war das?
Hat er nicht irgendeinen Rucksack irgendwo hingestellt und ist dann weggerannt?
So nach dem Motto, als würde es gleich explodieren?
Irgendwie sowas hat er doch getrieben in der Richtung.
Und, ähm...
Ich meine, da war keine Bombe drin, aber sie haben das halt glaubhaft, glaubhaft inszeniert.
So, dass Leute gesagt haben, sie haben dann, sie haben davon quasi Angstzustände gekriegt.
Was ich irgendwo nachvollziehen kann, ja?
Ähm...
Und...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es stimmt, dass er im Knast war, aber ich glaube, er war zumindest in Untersuchungshaft oder sowas.
Also, voll für den Arsch.
Voll, voll beknackt, ja.
Ja, komplett brain-off, genau.
Genau, Klicks plus 30 IQ.
Dann hast du halt das in Kombination.
Ähm...
Entrops, das stimmt.
Ähm, es gibt im englischen Bereich natürlich noch viel größeren Bullshit, keine Frage.
Aber ich finde, das Gesamtpaket ist in Deutschland einfach zu 90% kompletter Crap.
Und du hast zumindest im englischsprachigen Raum noch viele Sachen, die man gucken kann und auch immer mehr Sachen, die man gucken kann, die was taugen.
Natürlich ist der, natürlich ist der Ober-Crap internationaler Crap.
Weil...
Die Deutschen machen das halt irgendwann dann auch nach, ja?
Flow 96.
Brite zermelt 40 Mikrowelle auf den Kopf.
Was?
Oh man.
YouTube, Alter, YouTube.
Mal kurz die mal anschmeißen.
Süd.
Ähm, ja, also wie gesagt, sobald die Xen-Levels fertig sind...
...werden wir uns tatsächlich noch einmal Black Mesa...
...angucken.
Es ist jetzt letztens erst eine Public Beta gestartet.
Ja.
Xen-Level Public Beta.
Wo haben sie denn die News?
News?
Da sind immer die News auf der Seite.
Ach hier, Updates.
Mini-Update.
Juli-Update.
Summary-Release-Dates.
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Am 1. August gibt's die Public Beta von, ähm...
...von dem ersten Xen-Level und...
...dem...
...diesem Krabben.
Die Alien-Krabbe, die wir eben gesehen haben im Half-Life 1 Speedrun.
Das Level mit der Alien-Krabbe und das erste Xen-Level.
Und danach kommen die anderen drei.
Okay.
Also, wenn das in diesem Tempo weitergeht, wie es die letzten Jahre weiterging...
...können wir uns freuen, wenn es Ende des Jahres soweit ist, wenn überhaupt...
...dass die Xen-Levels rauskommen.
Und wenn die Xen-Levels draußen sind...
...dann...
...gucken wir uns...
...gucken wir uns nochmal das komplette, komplette Projekt an.
Kennst du Projekt Borealis?
Nee.
Sagt mir nix.
Gönn dir...
Okay.
Guck ich mir mal an.
Was ist das?
Okay.
Oh, da sehe ich einen Half-Life-Mod.
Das können wir uns echt angucken.
Vielleicht...
...gibt's ja irgendwann mal Half-Life 3.
Aber eh nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich Gaben überhaupt als Overlay hab.
Warum hab ich Gaben als Overlay?
Oh, meine Katze macht Krach.
Wartet mal.
Chico, was ist los?
Die hat nur Zeug vom Schrank runtergeschmissen.
Also alles halb so wild.
Okay, was ist das?
Projekt Borealis Update 5.
Max, welches Bildbearbeitungsprogramm kannst du empfehlen?
Naja, nachdem ich der absolute Technik-Noob bin...
...äh...
...der absolute kreative Bildbearbeitungs-Noob bin...
...hab ich das da.
Das da hab ich.
Ich accepte das alles.
Ist gut.
Ähm...
Für Noobs wie mich ist das optimal.
Weil selbst damit krieg ich gescheite YouTube-Thumbnails hin.
Und das reicht mir.
Und es kostet nicht viel.
Oh.
Und ich hab den Chat in meiner Vorschau gerade kaputt gemacht.
So, jetzt.
Was hältst du vom...
...Xuantai...
...910 von Alibaba?
Weiß ich nicht.
Muss ich mir mal angucken.
Was ist das überhaupt?
Okay.
Wir machen uns aber jetzt erstmal den Trailer an für...
...diesen Half-Life-Mod.
Sound aus.
Sound an.
Das ist ja voll...
...voll PRO, wie die das machen, äh.
...
Okay, es ist noch nicht richtig texturiert, aber
das ist ja nicht wild.
Sound an.
Das.
Es gibt einen Teil unseres Skripts, in dem Gordon allein durch perillöse Eisbäume und verlassenen Tunneln reist.
Und in Tunneln.
Um anfangen zu machen, nutzen unsere KonzeptartistInnen diesen Teil unseres Skripts, um initiale Storyboards und artistische Thesen zu erschaffen, die den Mood und Ton für die Gegend einstellen.
Mit diesen Schriftstücken, zusammen mit real-world-Lokationen für Inspiration, hat einer unserer Level-Designer Top-Down-Sketche aus einem vorgelegten Level-Layout geschaffen.
Sie detaillieren den gewünschten Weg des Spielers, zusammen mit großen Features, Obstakeln, Alliieren und Feinden, die auf dem Weg entstanden sind.
Diese Schriftstücke wurden dann benutzt, um die frühe In-Engine-Design des Levels zu beurteilen, mit grundlegenden Formen für schnelle Iterationen.
Diese Block-Outs gaben uns viel...
...Flow und Layout des Levels, bevor weitere Gameplay-Elemente eingeführt werden.
Wir können die I.I. einstellen und durch den Level spielen, um den Layout...
Sind das... sind das diese... Saugdinger? Die mit dem Tentakel? Soll das so ein Monster sein mit dem Tentakel dran?
Weiß ich, wie die Dinger in Half-Life heißen? Die dich so hochsaugen und dann reinbeißen?
...major Features, iterating as we go.
Once the level had reached a place where we were satisfied with the layout and flow,
our concept artist jumped back in to create a new round of refining...
...concepts.
Die wollen's ja voll wissen, ey!
...based directly on perspectives from the level block-out...
...and detail what those areas might look like when filled with textures and props.
Armed with both the block-out and concept art, the 3D team could now start creating assets, textures and props to bring the level to life.
This level has now had a first art pass, which focuses on tackling the most important features of the level.
From here, our artist will continue layering details into the environment...
...until the level is deemed complete.
Since our last update, we've been continuing to refine the core Project Borealis gameplay experience across a wide range of areas.
We now have early Combine AI implementation, improved physics, dynamic snow, graphics and audio enhancements, and much more.
To demonstrate our progress, we'd like to share some games...
Wow, müssen die eigentlich AI selbst programmieren? Source Engine hat doch bestimmt schon ordentlich AI drinne.
...auch noch nicht.
...play from a level segment that sees Gordon infiltrating a Combine facility.
Please keep in mind that much of what you'll see here is still a placeholder and not representative of final gameplay.
Throughout the video, the music you'll hear is assembled dynamically by dividing the full track into its components and then layering them.
This layering varies based on the current gameplay environment in addition to the player's location and actions.
...in addition to the player's location and actions.
Der Sound ist cool. Ist das der Originalsound? Hört sich irgendwie wuchtiger an.
Abgesegnet!
Ach, das ist Unreal 4!
Ja, stimmt, Leute, jetzt wo ihr jetzt sagt, das sieht überhaupt nicht nach Source aus, ja.
Siehst du auch an den ganzen Spiegelungen und so, das sieht, jetzt wo ich mir das richte, das sieht wirklich nicht nach Source aus.
Moment, wenn das in Unreal 4 ist, dann kann es doch durchaus sein, dass es dann im nächsten Schluss ist, oder?
Vielleicht sagt Valve dann irgendwann, ihr dürft nicht.
Huge Aim.
Wäre es nicht einfacher gewesen, das Source-technisch nachzubauen als in einer komplett neuen Engine?
Zumal ich mir vorstellen könnte, wenn man das auf Unreal 4 laufen lässt, dass dann Valve vielleicht was dagegen hat.
Wenn es ein weiterer Half-Life-Mod ist auf Source-Basis, auf Steam dann eher nicht, ja.
Oder ist das irgendwie abgesegnet?
Okay.
Die wollen, dass das Spiel neu aussieht. Ja, neu aussehen tut es.
Aber guck mal, Clarity Gun funktioniert auch schon halbwegs.
Na gut, der sieht jetzt nicht so ... auch cool.
Physics!
Ja gut, ich denk mal da bringt Unreal 4 schon viel mit.
Es ist wert zu bemerken, dass wir planen, von Physics zu Epics neuer Phyics-Engine, Chaos, und Amds neuem Mesh-Deformation-Tool, AMD FEM, zu bewegen.
Das ist ja cool.
Zuerst einmal, um den visuellen Effekt der Gravity Gun zu erhöhen,
die Waffe effizient die Items auf der Anlage zu bewegen, während sie die Objekte anbieten und sie anbewegen.
Weil das im original Half-Life 2 auch schon ziemlich gut funktioniert hat.
Fuck!
Bisschen übertrieben vielleicht?
Ich meine, das ist schon cool. Die Frage ist halt...
Also erstens, braucht man das in einem Half-Life-Spiel? Ich meine, Half-Life 2 war sehr Physik-lastig.
Und kostet das nicht so viel Zeit, dass man quasi für das eigentliche Game wenig hat.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall richtig, richtig gut. Das ist übelst nice.
Wir haben auch ein Air-Drag-System implementiert, das mit physischen Items in realistischen Formen interagiert.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man ein Objekt mit der Gravitationswaffe startet.
Um mit dem Chaos-Physik-Engine zu migrieren, haben wir mit dem Nvidia-Blast-Destruktion-Tool im Spiel gearbeitet.
Okay, das ist was, das ist natürlich schon ein bisschen advancer als das, was damals Half-Life 2 gemacht hat.
Ich meine, das ist schon echt nice.
Ich meine, das ist richtig cool, oder?
Das ist echt cool.
Wir arbeiten jetzt an anderen Wegen, wie wir die Technologie in das Spiel einbringen können,
z.B. durch destruktive Szenerie.
Ein Fokus auf Optimierung lässt uns diese Systeme in einer Art und Weise implementieren,
die Physik-Interaktionen zwischen Hunderten von Objekten in realer Zeit unterstützt.
Und ohne einen bedeutenden Effekt auf die Leistung.
Dies bietet uns die Flexibilität, neue Gameplay-Optionen zu erforschen,
die in älteren Enginen nicht so einfach erzielt werden könnten.
In Zuge der Features, die wir so weit herausgebracht haben,
haben wir auch Zeit gespart, Audio-Technologie zu entwickeln und zu implementieren.
Wir nutzen Steam-Audio, um Reverb, Ekklusion und Spatialisierung zu behandeln,
während wir auch überlegen, wie die Geräusche aufgrund ihrer Frequenz propagieren.
Letztendlich haben wir viele neue Konzepte zu teilen.
Wir haben nur Zeit, ein paar Teile in diesem Video zu zeigen,
aber wir haben die Medien-Sektion unserer Website überwacht,
mit viel mehr.
Einer der Herausforderungen, Modelle von Spiele,
die über 10 Jahre hergestellt wurden,
ist, niedrige Resolution-Technologien zu verwenden.
... und Details für höhere Resolution-Modelle zu interpretieren.
Im Falle von kombinierten Paneelen, zum Beispiel,
mussten wir neue Konzept-Arten produzieren,
um zu visualisieren, welche Features von den Objekten
oder Räumen von Knöpfen,
Dialen,
Switchen,
Räumen,
...
Ich meine, das ist schon echt nice, ja.
Und die meinen das ernst, sonst hätten die nicht, würden sie nicht einen Aufriss machen, ne?
Die meinen das auf jeden Fall ernst.
Wenn Sie sich interessieren, mehr über eine bestimmte Rolle zu lernen, können Sie auf unserer Webseite www.projektborealis.com besuchen, wo Sie mehr über jede der verfügbaren Positionen lesen können.
Ein direkter Link zur offiziellen Openings-Page der Projekt Borealis kann in der Videobeschreibung unten gefunden werden.
Wenn Sie eine Rolle sehen, die Sie interessiert und Sie ein paar Stunden pro Woche an den Projekt anbieten können, empfehlen wir Ihnen, sich anzupassen.
Um mit dem Projekt abzudecken, können Sie sich auf den Projekt Borealis-Kanal hier auf YouTube abgeben,
folgen uns auf Twitter, abonnieren uns auf unserer Webseite oder kommen Sie mit uns auf unsere Projektborealis-Kanale.
Ein direkter Link zur offiziellen Openings-Page der Projekt Borealis-Kanale.
Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie Javascript.
Ist es Javascript?
Ne, es ist kein Javascript.
Es ist...
Was ist das für eine Sprache?
Rust?
Ne.
Was ist das?
Was ist das für eine Sprache?
Ich erkenne die Endung da hinten nicht dran.
Was ist das?
Windows Z ist Lupe, ne?
Ne.
Zoom.
Lens.
Das wird aber halt nichts bringen, weil der Stream so schlecht aufgelöst.
Ich erkenne es nicht.
Was könnte es für eine Sprache sein?
Was ist das?
Swift!
Ja!
Der Captain Seeker, das könnte tatsächlich Swift sein.
Er sollte vielleicht die Schrift...
Also wenn man seinen Editor streamt, sollte man vielleicht auch gucken, dass der Editor...
Dass man das erkennt.
Videoschnitt.
Was gibt es denn hier alles?
Twitch hängt.
Es ist...
Sony Vegas.
Irgendwie nichts bei.
Oder?
24-7 Cannabis.
Warum nicht?
Chat Overlay as a Service.
Hauptsache alles as a Service.
Wann gibt es Cloud as a Service?
Ich will meine eigene Cloud, aber ich will sie nicht selbst bauen.
As a Service.
Just Chatting.
Auf Deutsch.
Was haben wir denn da so alles?
Grills.
Ja.
Eieiei.
Der edelste aller Hunde ist der Hotdog.
Das ist doch schlecht, ey.
Okay, es sind alle am Futtern irgendwie.
Zucchini Brownies.
Oh!
Come on, bruh!
Ich meine, ich saft dich.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es funktioniert, aber klingt nicht gut.
So viele Mädels hier.
Guck dir das mal an.
Haben wir einen deutschen Overwatch-Streamer?
Overwatch.
Ja, weil haben wir da einen auf Deutsch?
Einer, den ich kenne vielleicht.
Also man muss echt sagen, der Frauen-Anteil auf Twitch ist die letzten zwei Jahre extrem gestiegen.
Und vor allem keine Bootcamp-Streams oder ganz normale Streams.
Das heißt, das hätte man sich vor ein paar Jahren noch gar nicht vorstellen können.
Streaming-Grills.
Okay, kenne ich keinen hiervon.
Bob Ross.
Gut, Leute, ich weiß nicht, wen ich hosten sollte.
Äh, wen ich hosten kann.
Ich hoste keinen. Ich gehe jetzt erst mal was futtern.
Weil eigentlich
war der Stream, wie gesagt, zum Aufwachen gedacht.
Und wir haben jetzt fast 14 Uhr.
Ich würde sagen, wir sind nach dreieinhalb Stunden sind verwacht.
Aber Schluss. Bis denn.
Macht's gut.
C.U.